Hey everybody,
what's up?
How was your weekend?
Don't answer that.
We're not really talking.
That's just the awkward thing though.
The get the get the podcast started words,
they don't really mean anything.
It takes a few words from here on out.
Everything means something.
Allegedly.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by Squarespace.
Congratulations to all those folks
who won the Squarespace contest.
He should be getting all your goods,
your higher prime meat tee shirt and your
swag bag from Squarespace and you get
a free year of Squarespace service.
There was some really cool,
um,
entrance,
a lot of them really too many to,
to pick four,
but we managed to pick four that we're,
uh,
we're pretty striking.
So,
uh,
the what,
what Squarespace is for people to,
in going,
what the fuck's he talking about?
Squarespace is a fantastic
website for creating websites.
It's really intuitive,
super easy to use.
It's one that I've had
virtually zero complaints about,
not virtually actually when
I say virtually because I
was trying to sound smart.
It seems like a good word to fit in there.
Um,
it's used by,
you know,
somebody,
different companies that would have
ordinarily had to pay someone a,
a tremendous amount of money to create
something just as cool and slick the way
they have it is set up so that if you
can do normal computer things like go
online,
dragon drop,
you know,
click on things.
It's,
if you could do like normal
things in the Internet,
create a word document,
you could figure out how to make your
own beautiful website with things like
having an online store,
very easy to set up for musicians,
musicians can sell digital
music from Squarespace.
It's just a really cool company that
it just a product that's excellent and
works really well.
And for a free trial and
10% off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter in the
code Joe and the number one that's Joe
and the number one for this month
of January that we're in right now.
Squarespace has also launched a new
help website that will deliver better
customer service.
They actually have an ad
running during the Superbowl.
Damn Squarespace is stepping up.
Um,
it's beautiful designs for you to start
with and a lot of style options you need
create a unique website.
The ones that were entered
into the contest were,
were really excellent.
Just a perfect examples of what
can be done because it really,
you still look,
you know,
like most people's websites,
you either had someone make it a new
what they're doing or your website looks
like shit,
but now you can make your
own and it looks awesome.
squarespace.com use the offer
code Joe and the number one,
that's all one word,
Joe and the number one for a free
trial and 10% off your first purchase.
Their ad has a new creepy baby guy.
Creepy baby holding a guy.
That's a baby.
Wow.
Why are you trying to freak me out man?
I know your bet.
They're trying to freak me out.
That is weird.
These babies in weird
ways and w commercials,
it's very unusual the just for men
baby and is this a bunch of like weird
commercials with babies?
Get to talk babies,
do things that normal people do.
We're fucking weird man.
Humans are weird.
Anyway,
we're also brought to you by legal zoom.
Um,
much like Squarespace,
which a lot of our friends
have used legal zoom.
It's been used by a lot of our friends
on it was formed through legal zoom.
Brian formed his death squad
company through legal zoom.
You can't get a better,
simpler,
easier way to to do law type shit that
you would ordinarily have to go to a
lawyers office for.
You would not ordinarily,
you'd have to make an appointment,
he'd have to go there.
You'd have to wait in line.
You'd have to,
I don't know if you wait in line,
you have to wait to wait.
I don't think there's a line.
I'm exaggerating.
The point is it costs a lot of
fucking money to go to the lawyer,
but you can start a business
incorporate or start an lll LLC.
Well,
I don't know what an ELA is,
but you can start an LLC,
which is like limited
legal something or another.
What does that stand for?
Limited liability company.
Yeah,
and you could do that for just 99 bucks.
You can also do a last
will for just 69 bucks,
get a living trust,
power of attorney,
more,
all that kind of stuff.
And legal zoom also has a connection
to a series of independent attorney.
So if you panic and you're like,
this is the fuck I can't do this,
legal zoom will connect you to independent
attorneys who can help you through
the process,
help you through your process.
Um,
if you're in the middle
of it and you're like,
this can't be legal,
I'm going to jail.
I'm scared.
I need to talk to a real lawyer.
Don't panic legals and we'll hook you up.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect to you with a third
party attorney and provide you with
self help services.
And now you get a special discount
from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the referral
box at checkout for more savings.
Um,
this is probably the easiest way,
ladies and gentlemen,
that you can be naked and do law.
You can do legal things
completely naked from the freedom.
Yeah,
but you've got to put a
piece of tape over your,
you're a little webcam because
the fucking government,
man,
they're sneaking in there looking at you.
Do you have a piece of
tape over their address?
Even better.
I have an eff sticker.
Eff The electronic frontier foundation
that fights for civil liberties on the
Internet and they have their own brand.
It's thinkers you can buy,
so they have their own
stickers that cover webcams.
Yes,
and they don't,
they don't leave.
They don't leave glue residue.
So you can peel it off and put it back
on if you want to talk someone into do
video.
Right.
It's beautiful.
Yeah.
It's a great little thing.
The Internet,
you can't fuck with the Internet.
It's too strong.
It got out of control.
You fucked up government,
I think.
Just keep it on the government.
You fucked up.
You messed up.
He just,
an Internet was your downfall.
When they go look in the history of
the human beings and they go back to
different errors,
they will look at the,
the history of the Internet called bullae.
They didn't see that coming.
Oh my goodness.
Anyway on the Internet,
go to legal zoom.com how about that?
Get yourself an LLC.
The is right.
Uh,
patents and things.
Well,
that's the most important
thing that I'll see on legal.
Zoom did gym.
The thing is a lot of this law
stuff is not that complicated,
but they make you pay,
you know,
150 bucks to do it with an attorney and
they really just fill in a form for you.
Most people can do it themselves,
so it's,
yeah,
it works.
It's great.
It's a trap.
It's a trap,
but for now,
legal zooms legal.
Who knows what's going to happen.
Go there.
Legal zoom.com and a used the row,
the word Rogan in the referral
box at checkout for more savings.
We're also brought to you
by on@dotcomonig.com the
human optimization website.
What is essentially is
all things that I use,
whether it's a physical fitness equipment,
strength and conditioning equipment
like kettle bells or battle ropes or ab
wheels or anything that we find that
is that can aid human performance,
whether it's human physical performance,
whether it's cognitive performance,
whether it aids and enhancing your mood.
We actually have a supplement called new
mood that's a five HTP and l tryptofan
supplement that actually enhances your
body's ability to produce dopamine.
It makes you feel better.
So much so that there's people that are
on antidepressants or their doctors tell
them to not take five HTP cause you
don't want to get too much of that.
Good loving too much of that.
Yeah.
What's that?
Ecstasy like?
Why?
Why wouldn't you want to go to,
I guess serotonin
overload or something like that?
You can,
you kind of real issues.
You're not,
you know,
it's like too much of a bat,
a good thing.
It's still bad.
That's why if guys do steroids and
they get to be 350 pounds there,
Dick just shuts down your Dick's
done too much of a good thing.
You know,
your liver is freaking out.
It's got to process all the shit
that you're pumping into it.
It's all about balance,
balance and uh,
all the things that on it.
Um,
whether it's uh,
the strength and conditioning equipment
or the supplements I'll share that I
use.
And if we find something out there,
we tried to sell it.
We tried to sell you the best coconut oil.
We tried to sell you
the best buffalo bars,
best hemp seed oil from the finest hemp
seed with the highest levels of protein
in it.
We just tried to sell you the very
best shit available and we sell some
controversial things,
uh,
things like nootropics.
And we,
uh,
we funded a double blind placebo study
that we'll be able to talk more about in
February,
but we were spending a lot of money
to back up the existing science on
nootropics because I know a lot of
people fear that things are snake oil.
And I,
I,
that's a good fear.
It's good.
And it's good because it forces companies
who sell legitimate things to do the
proper testing and just show you,
there's plenty of examples
of things on late night TV.
They're telling you that your Dick's
going to grow or you know this.
I mean that's just one example of things
that you know are dubious and you know
they're making money because if they
weren't making money they wouldn't be
having these commercials.
There is nothing that
makes your Dick Rowe.
If they did on it would have
it on the God damn front page.
We'd have Dick Rowe pills,
weed,
fucking sell them,
buy crates.
The shit doesn't work.
Nothing makes your Dick Rowe.
Okay.
Did the moment they figure it out.
Go to on.com O.
N.
I.
T.
We'll fucking have it.
If there's something out there,
we'll have it,
but until now we're just trying to
sell you this stuff that does work.
Because of the controversy.
We have a very loose
money back guarantee on,
on their supplements,
on things like new mood or Alpha brain.
There is a 90 pill,
30 day,
100% money back guarantee.
Excuse me,
30 pill
coffin here,
I reversed it.
It's a 30 pill,
90 day.
So the first 30 pills,
you have a 90 day 100%
money back guarantee and you
don't even have to return
the product.
You don't have to send it back in.
You just,
you use what you just said.
This stuff's socks.
You get your money back.
The what we're trying to do is sell you
something that is so good that you don't
have that temptation.
And if you honestly do try Alpha brain
and you say it didn't do anything for
you,
I want you to have your money back.
I think that's good.
Don't buy it.
And again,
don't,
don't buy it anymore.
And you know,
maybe it's just not for you,
but that's,
I don't,
I don't want anybody to feel ripped off.
We're so confident that what we're
selling is effective and works for us.
That we're willing to have such a,
uh,
a loose and limber moneyback guarantee,
but we're just going to continue to try
to sell you the best shit that we can
find.
And,
uh,
whatever science that we can
do on one of her supplements,
we will absolutely do that as well.
You use a codeword Rogan and you will
save 10% off any and all supplements.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
thanks to everybody who
came out to Chicago.
We had a great fucking
time this past weekend.
It was cold as shit,
but the people are cool as fuck.
Um,
Andreas Antonopoulos is here.
We're going to talk about cryptocurrency
and we're going to let some bitches,
no,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Hey Joe Rogan podcast all day.
So I love the fact that you can get on
the Internet and you have a conversation
on Twitter with anybody and
the word bitcoin comes up.
And then this swarm of people from
like all these different directions.
Andreas Antonopoulos,
judge,
Bitcoin,
Jesus,
g,G ,
G,
g.
So you know,
eye contact,
you,
you contact me.
Boom.
A week later we're sitting in front of
each other and want to talk about bitcoin
in a million.
People are going to hear about it.
I mean,
does the Internet is fucking beautiful.
It's magic.
I mean it's just,
it is what it should have.
The would communication with human
beings should have been a long time ago.
I think it would have all the things
that took off and gained ground and gain
momentum throughout human history,
whether it's religion or
whether it's colt rituals,
ritualistic behavior like the,
all that shit wouldn't have
happened if the Internet was around.
The Internet would have went under Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
It's not that.
It's this,
why does it,
does it stop?
What are you saying?
Look right here.
Here's,
here's the studies.
There's so much misconception and so
disinformation that human beings have been
fed throughout history.
I think we're just now starting to grasp
how huge it is that this is the first
time in history where information just
flows just back and forth and the most
valuable stuff is free.
The most valuable information
that you can get online,
absolutely free,
which is,
you know what's the best thing about the
internet is that it's a dumb network.
It transmits information from point a
to point B and it doesn't care what that
information is.
So if you come up with a new idea,
a new application,
and you stick it on the
edge of the network,
you can transmit that
information to anybody else.
And there's a cellist principle behind it,
net neutrality that you don't prioritize
your content instead of somebody
else's,
you allow equal access
to all for all contents.
And the Internet doesn't care.
It's just Ip.
All that seizes bites
and it just moves them.
And then one day somebody invented a new
application and stuck it on the edge,
the Internet of money.
And that's what I'm here to talk about
today because they didn't need to ask
anybody permission.
And they launched bitcoin and it happened.
And now that it's here,
it's enabling other people to launch money
applications on the Internet and it's
going to fuel the Internet even
faster than we've seen before.
Yeah,
this is a very strange time,
uh,
in,
in that there's actually people that
are just starting to accept bitcoin.
One of the first crypto currencies for,
for solid objects like tiger direct
is starting to accept bitcoin.
For computers.
You can order a computer on tiger
direct from fucking bitcoins.
And I'll send you a God damn actual
computer that you can get online with that
starts becoming real
well tiger direct can very simply take
that bit coin and immediately converted
into dollars so they don't even have
any exchange risk and other people are
willing to give them dollars for
it because they see it as valuable.
And that's all money is.
It's a shared understanding that this
thing has value because it's scarce that
it's not around a lot.
It's hard to make.
You can't copy it,
you can't fake it.
And once you have those three things,
you have money.
Okay,
then it has value.
Plain those.
How is it possible?
Well,
what exactly is bitcoin for people that
are completely on the outside on this
and they listen to this
podcast and I'm like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
New Money,
bitcoin.
What is,
what is a bitcoin?
So there's layers to this.
I'll start at the top layer at the top.
Player.
Bitcoin is cash on the intranet and I say
cash because it's not just any kind of
money.
It's not like an account or credit card.
It's not like paypal.
This is cash,
which means that when you have it,
you have it sitting on your
computer as digital cash.
And then when you send it,
it goes directly from your computer to
the recipients wallet as digital cash.
Now that's the top layer underneath.
This is basically a shared ledger.
That means that everyone can see all of
the transactions and the whole network
agrees that Andrea sent Joe,
you know,
a 10th of a bitcoin.
Great.
Now the whole network knows it.
So that means Joel has a 10th of a
bitcoin and simply based on that,
you can move money around.
Um,
there's a lot of security
in some complex math,
but basically bitcoin is a standard.
It's an agreement on how to
exchange money on the Internet,
just like the web is a standard on
how to create pages and view them in a
browser.
There's a lot of skepticism
when it comes to bitcoin.
Um,
uh,
I've spoken to people that are financial
wizards that are skeptical and I've
spoken to people that are just,
you know,
the that have just looked
into cryptocurrencies
because of the rise of the
popularity of bitcoin.
They said,
this doesn't make sense.
There's no room for inflation.
There's not enough people,
not enough bitcoins does it?
It's not going to work.
How are they going to create more?
There's all these different arguments
about why do you think that what we're
seeing with the rise of bitcoin is
instead of just addressing all these
financial concerns and all these people
that are used to the current market and
the place that it's at right now,
the the the,
the standards that the way they run things
instead of that bitcoin just creates
a completely new network driven community
driven money and says fuck all your
old rule.
It's social network of funny.
It's peer to peer money.
It means to wrecked from one individual
to another individual no matter where
they are on the world in seconds for
almost free and that has never happened
before.
Do you think that part of the skepticism
though is because of the fact this
other system exists?
Sure.
And that this other system is our norm,
our standard.
And we don't want to look
at like something like
bitcoin objectively just say,
okay,
let's pretend that our current
system of stocks and bonds,
but it's not just,
yeah,
and it's not just the system.
It's so much part of our culture.
Money is one of the first technologies,
you know,
fire wheel money.
Money has existed for tens
of thousands of years,
going back to shells and feathers and
knots on string and giant rocks in the
Polynesian islands and then through the
Iron Age to minted coins stamped with
emperors faces.
This stuff has been part of our
culture for tens of thousands of years.
And as a result,
it's no longer just technology.
It's a cultural phenomenon and you are
steeped in it from the moment you're
born.
And so you acquire certain notions
of what money is and how it works.
And you think that the current system
by which money works is the only system
because we've had it
for thousands of years.
And even in computer science,
the idea of getting distributed
computers to agree on something without
cheating,
we thought that problem couldn't be solved
until 2008 when the invention behind
bitcoin solve that problem and
created a new way of doing money.
And it's going to take a lot
of time to understand it.
Primarily because people don't really
understand money as it is today.
They don't understand how banks work.
They understand how the
Federal Reserve creates money.
They don't understand a
debt based system for money.
I've read about it.
I don't understand it.
Well,
I read,
I read many things.
I've watched documentaries understand it.
Most of the people when
they first face bitcoin,
they start asking questions about money
and it quickly becomes apparent to all
of us when we do this,
that we don't know much about money.
So then we learned about money
and we start reading about money.
But um,
you know,
it's,
it's very much part of the culture to
the point where I'll talk to people about
bitcoin and they'll say,
well,
it's not backed by gold.
So how can it have value?
The dollar hasn't been backed
by gold for like 60 years in,
and you talk to the average person in
the streets and they still think there's
some gold in a vault
and that stuff does it.
It doesn't exist.
I'm happen to all the
gold in the vault watches.
Well,
that's a whole other question.
I mean,
the real issue is this heath,
we haven't been on a gold standard for
decades and all of the currencies in the
world are created based on the productive
capacity of the country and the legal
system,
and because they have value,
because you pay your taxes with them and
then they just float freely in exchange
rates.
So they very against each other in the,
because the dollar is used to buy oil,
it's the world reserve currency and
all the other currencies are measured
against that,
but there is no gold and that's fine.
That doesn't mean it doesn't have value.
It absolutely has.
That fucks up a lot of old action movies,
man.
Yeah,
it really does.
Those movies where you
would break into the vault.
Yeah,
Lone Ranger.
The bars of gold there would
always be brick shaped.
Well the thing is gold isn't
that efficient for building
a currency on because
the rates of which you can produce gold,
um,
is his face.
Then it's hoarded and you know,
you have certain problems.
Now the Nice thing about
bitcoin is that it takes,
um,
it takes the same concept of scarcity a,
of having something that
is a limited resource,
but it does it by algorithm.
So you essentially have math
that says that every 10 minutes,
25 new bitcoin is created by the network
as a whole with all of the computing
capacity of the network.
And that's fixed.
And every four years we create
half as much every 10 minutes.
So in four years it goes down to 12
and a half bitcoin every 10 minutes.
And then it goes down to six and a
quarter and it keeps going down until you
meant the last bit coin.
And then you're done 21 million coins.
It's done.
And the idea is that you
provide a sound basis for money.
Something that is rare,
cannot be forged,
is easily transportable.
And that is the form of currency.
So 21 million bitcoins and then it's over.
They will,
well,
there's our,
you can divide a Bitcoin,
100 million pieces,
so it goes down to eight digits.
And that means the lowest
units is called a Satoshi.
And there's 100 million
satoshis in a bitcoin.
So 21 million times 100 million,
21 quadrillion coins,
plenty coins.
Jesus Christ.
Why am,
why is that so complicated?
Why is it like 100 million?
Um,
well I think part of the reason is that
it's easier to write a number without a
decimal points and just to write a
smaller units with lots of Zeros after it.
Um,
it's easier in computer terms,
the handle numbers that way,
but,
but most importantly,
it doesn't matter because what you see
on your screen at today might be a bit
coin.
Actually,
on my wallets,
I use Millie bet coins,
thousands of a bitcoin because of
corresponds more to my daily purchases.
You know,
maybe a few years from now you're going
to be using a millions of a bitcoin to
look at your balance.
It doesn't matter what you call a unit.
Uh,
the point is what value
does it have because someone
else is willing to give you
that amount of money.
Well,
but we have like sort of this
established ideal in our hand,
what a dollar is worth.
This is a $100 that looks like
a thousand dollar computer.
Sure.
You know,
we have this idea in our head and that
idea will be completely out the window.
And you started talking about millions
of bitcoins and trying to like figure out
like how much is a laptop from tiger dot.
If I buy a laptop,
is that 200 millions of a bitcoin?
Well,
no,
we just talk in millibits and
millibit is almost about a dollars.
It's about 800 something today.
Um,
so,
uh,
middle of bed.
So a computer with cost
you about 1200 millivolts,
1200 megabits.
All right,
that seems normal as long as we can get
it down to numbers that like correspond
with dollars.
But here's the thing,
do you know what I mean?
This is a global
bull phenomenon and there are so many
countries out there whether currency,
very 30% a year and some
now for 30% a month.
And in those countries there is no
stable anything and even the dollar,
we look at it today and we have
this idea of what its value is,
but if you look back historically it's
value has been declining for almost a
century now and today's dollar
is worth the same as you know,
13 cents at the beginning
of the previous century.
We don't see that on a day to day base
because it's one of the most stable
currencies,
but there's 193 currencies out
there and 180 of them are far,
far worse than the dollar
in terms of management.
And a couple of handful of
them absolutely horrible.
And the people trapped in these
countries can now use bitcoin.
So this is a lot broader
than just the U s dollar.
It's not just a matter of is this
going to be comfy for consumers?
This can bring people from
countries that have extreme poverty,
extreme problems,
that are not necessarily
based on a lack of technology,
that have phones,
that can use bitcoin for example.
But because of politics that
trapped in this situation recently,
I was in Argentina in Buenos Iris and
now they're having an even worst currency
crisis.
Uh,
they devalued 18% last week,
uh,
locked that lockdown.
They can't take money out of the country.
They can't buy things online.
If they buy something online,
they have to go pick it up from a
customs office and pay 50% tax on it.
The,
the countries trying to lock in the money,
right?
And you have these extreme situations
and then you have a choice suddenly.
So bitcoin is a lot bigger than just,
you know,
a consumer thing for here in the u s
how would someone get bitcoins
from those environments?
Like,
so let's say you're in some poor third
world country with a really incredibly
corrupt system and fucked up economy.
How someone from
that,
that environment get a bitcoin?
Well.
So,
um,
even in Argentina for example,
which is not,
uh,
you know,
this a second world
country that was once the,
you know,
the Paris of Latin America and
it's still a beautiful place.
Um,
but it has these difficult
political problems.
It's illegal to trade on the
black market dollars for pesos,
right?
So you can't go in and if
you're a tourist and say,
okay,
I'm just going to give some
dude on the street to hundred,
that's illegal.
And yet on every street corner,
the someone who will sell you pesos.
And last time I went to,
I just asked them,
will you take bitcoin?
And guess what?
Some of them said,
never heard of it.
And some of them said,
yeah,
we're trying to do that now.
Can you help us?
Whoa.
So suddenly you have Jordi have this black
market or gray market for currencies.
And,
and in the u s you never see this,
but if you travel abroad,
you see this all the time.
Most places in the world,
the official currency rate versus
the one you can get from a corner.
Uh,
you know,
a street sale seller who is,
selling vegetables and the
local currency for dollars.
You know,
you can do that to ever in so
many countries in the world.
And for them it's a normal thing.
Now,
this,
this novel idea of this new currency,
is this something that anyone
right now is Lik living off of?
Is anybody getting paid by bitcoin and
paying their rent by bitcoin buying their
food with bitcoin?
So first of all,
my income is entirely,
bitcoin has been for several months now.
How many months?
Um,
since October perhaps.
And before that I just didn't have as
much income because I've been working on
Bitcoin,
you know,
to,
to a level almost obsession because it's
such a fascinating technology for me.
And as someone who works in
security and distributed systems,
this is,
you know,
a once in a lifetime opportunity to
be involved in something monumental.
Just like when I was involved in
the early days of the Internet as,
as a,
as a young scientist and now I
can do it again with bitcoin.
So I've been obsessed,
but since October I've also been making
a living off bitcoin and I get paid in
bitcoin.
Wow.
And how do you pay your rent?
I convert some of it to dollars to pay
my landlord until I can persuade them to
take bitcoin directly.
But it won't take that long because
every time I pay in dollars I say,
would you rather take bitcoin?
And that's one of the easiest
ways to get bitcoin by the ways.
So find someone who wants to
pay for something with bitcoin.
Wow.
And so they're not ready to yet,
but you think that perhaps
they're thinking about it.
I might be able to pay
your rent in bitcoin.
I'm
always surprised by WHO's
going to take my bitcoin.
Sometimes it's a taxi driver in Germany.
Sometimes you know it's a,
it's a give it to them that they
install an app on their phone.
I'm going to give you some before
the end of the show for sure.
They installed an APP on their phone and
I just zap it across just like I could
zap it from hair to Kuala
Lumpur in two seconds.
I can stop it across the table.
Whoa.
It's just like sending an email and,
and in fact it's,
it's remarkably similar.
I just get,
you'll install an app and then
you'll give me your bitcoin address,
which is like your email kinda.
And then I'll zap some bitcoin across
the u and few seconds later you'll see it
pop up on your phone.
And that is real bitcoin.
It's,
and it's on your phone.
It's not sitting in a bank somewhere.
You don't have the promise that
maybe when you try to withdraw it,
you're going to have it.
This isn't,
you know,
a credit or something like that.
This is the actual digital
amount is locked by a key
that's on your phone and is
recognized by the entire
network is a valid transaction.
If you left your phone
behind in a drunken stupor,
someone got ahold of your phone,
could they wreck you financially?
Yeah.
Dammit.
Say No.
So No,
I'm going to be,
I'm going to be 100% honest.
There are,
there are ways to protect yourself.
So,
for example,
on mine,
phone wallet,
first of all it has my phone has a pin.
Then my wallet has a pin of its own.
And then there's one thing that I
can't do with a wallet right away,
which is I can't send money.
I can look at my balance,
I can receive money,
all of that just with a pin.
But if I want to send money and have to
enter another password or pin personal
identification numbers.
Yeah.
So I've got a couple of
different passwords so that
my wallet isn't just sitting
there.
But again,
as I said,
this is digital cash.
So if you had a wallet stuffed with
cash and you left isn't a cafe,
what happens to it?
Somebody steals it or
you get really lucky.
And so when he gives it back to you.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm some of that money.
Exactly.
But most likely,
you know,
you don't have someone to call and say,
Hey,
get that cash back for me.
It was stolen from so-and-so location.
It's gone back up.
Yes,
you lose your phone.
Can you back up from,
from a cloud.
Well,
that's the nice thing about it
because unlike physical money,
this is digital money.
You can make copies of it.
You can't spend both copies,
you can only spend one,
but you can make copies
so you can make backups.
You can even back up right
onto a piece of paper,
which is what I do in this
called a paper wallet.
So I have printed pieces of paper with
Bitcoin keys on them and I make two
copies and I put one in a safe and I put
the other in a safety deposit box and I
send bitcoin to those wallets.
And then I basically have my
bitcoin sitting on paper in a bank.
What kind of like a bearer bond?
It's like a bearer bonds,
you know,
or like a stock certificate.
But the only differences that that magic
number that's on there allows me to
redeem that bitcoin anywhere in the world.
This is way more sophisticated
than I thought it was.
I thought it was a bunch
of dorks running round,
fake fucking duns and dragons money.
Oh No,
this is,
this is way more sophisticated.
We'll get to talking about how
you can use this to do stocks,
bonds,
distributed companies,
autonomous companies.
Now when you pay your kinds of things,
when you pay your rent
and you take your bitcoin,
you convert it to money,
who's giving you money for Bitcoin?
People want to buy bitcoin.
So how do you find these
people on craigslist?
So there's a number of ways.
The,
the,
the uh,
the straightforward one,
if you come from the old banking style
world is you open a brokerage account on
a virtual currency exchange
that will exchange dollars,
yen,
euros,
whatever to bitcoin or even
some other cryptocurrencies.
And then you can go there
and you can wire transfer,
um,
you know,
using your bank account,
you can wire transfer money into the
brokerage account as you would to buy IBM
stock.
You wire him some money to your brokerage
and then you buy some IBM stock.
Well here you are some money there
and you buy some bitcoin with it.
Whoa.
So traditional brokerages
deal in Bitcoin as well.
No,
this is a specialized exchange
that deals in Bitcoin,
but it works just like
a brokerage account.
So you have a number of
different currencies in it
and you can buy one and sell
the other.
Are there any brokers
who deal in bitcoins,
uh,
of like traditional,
large scale?
No,
not yet.
Not yet.
But you think that's coming?
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Because the thing is,
it's,
it's a,
it's one of the skills they have,
right?
They also have the physical locations
and branches to sell bed coin and before
long board,
we're going to see as the same thing
that happened in the entertainment
industry.
When MP3 hit the scene.
Like at first everyone was like,
Whoa,
we don't want to even touch this.
And then somebody started thinking,
Hey,
if I start playing with
this before everybody else,
it's going to hurt all of us,
but it's going to hurt me less
than I can start taking advantage.
And they peel off the herd and boom,
you have adoption.
And I think the same thing is going
to start happening with banking.
Wow.
Some of the banks,
perhaps not the big six US banks,
they've got a nice,
uh,
comfortable,
$70 billion a month
from the Fed right now.
Why would they do innovation?
But maybe one of the
more nimble banks may be,
you know,
in,
in a country like Cyprus that's been hit
hard by these bail ins and you have a
very open banking environment.
Maybe Singapore is going to decide
this is a good strategic move.
May Been Mccall who knows.
The point is in an international
financial environment,
all it takes is one.
Yeah.
One ball gets rolling and then
creates the avalanche and then,
and then the stem piece and
then the standard changes.
Right.
Wow.
This is very exciting.
It's very complex though.
And this is what I'm trying
to wrap my head around.
The,
the amount of this bitcoin that's
created every year is limited in fixed.
Who determined all of this?
Who Do,
who created bitcoin?
Who invented the concept?
Was there several people or,
yeah,
you said when you exchanged money it's,
it's almost free.
I heard.
So that money goes somewhere.
Who's getting this money?
So this is where it gets
a bit more complicated.
And,
um,
but keep in mind the internet in 1992,
you had to know unix command line skills
to send an email and it took two days
across the network.
We can get simpler and easier
for most people over time,
but it's still a bit geeky.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll get into it.
One question at a time though.
Who created this?
So this was created by Satoshi Nakamoto,
a cryptographer who used an anonymous
identity or pseudonymous identity.
Uh,
he,
he basically wrote a paper
and the basic software,
a scientific paper that
explains how it works.
It's actually the best
way to understand bitcoin.
If you have a bit of understanding of,
of basic science,
you can,
you can read it.
It's very accessible.
And if you look for those Satoshi Nakamoto
bitcoin paper or the bitcoin paper,
you'll find it online.
Um,
so he wrote a paper and at the same time
he created the software that runs the
system,
right?
And then gave it out to people
and people started running it.
Now keep in mind,
bitcoin is an agreement.
It's a standard.
It's how you do certain things on
the bitcoin network that's matters,
right?
And then there's software that
implements that agreement.
The runs according to those rules,
just like the internet
doesn't belong to anyone,
is just an agreement of how you
transmit things across the Internet.
And then everybody can write
software that can use that standard.
So Satoshi Nakamoto created
the standards in 2008,
2008.
The paper came out in 2008 and followed
shortly thereafter by the code.
The discussion actually lasted about
a here as he was mulling this over and
discussing it.
And keep in mind,
digital money is not new.
We've been doing digital money
since the probably the mid eighties.
I think the first,
a notable one was David showmes,
Digi cash and he created a form of
digital money using the new technology of
cryptography at the time.
Um,
he and cryptography is,
is a way of scrambling and unscrambling
messages and doing digital signatures
and using mathematics to,
to prove things basically on computers.
It's also what you use to protect your
browsing session when you connect to your
bank and it puts that little
lock that's using cryptography,
you're doing an an an encrypted session.
So at the time,
uh,
David Chaum basically
created additional money.
And what it is is you can have a
number that has a signature on it,
the proof's who owns it.
And then you can spend that.
The problem is that you,
because it's digital,
you can copy it.
So what happens if you spend it twice?
Well,
you have to have some
kind of central authority,
the checks to see that
you don't spend it twice.
And so he put some servers together
and they could handle all of the
transactions and make sure nobody spent
the money twice and issue the money into
all of the kind of Federal Reserve Central
Bank functions and then ran it on the
network and it worked.
So unfortunately,
if you have a central server and you
try to go against the banking system,
they stomp on you.
So they stomp on you.
In this case,
uh,
there,
there was a series of legal battles and
then eventually the service got down.
And so we've seen this happen maybe four
or five times with different attempts
to do digital cash with various
levels of centralization.
But the basic problem was this,
how do you ensure that the
network remains trusted and honest
without having someone in the middle
who checks everything and authority?
How do you put trust?
Not In an institution or central
authority as most hierarchal system work,
but in a con,
but spread that trust
across the whole network.
And in 2008,
Satoshi Nakamoto solve that problem and
he solved it by putting together four or
five ideas that each of
them had been done somewhat
before,
but he put them together in an incredible
combination that just worked and
worked beautifully.
So what the system does is
it forces everyone who's
participating on the network
to do a bit of a computing,
um,
with our system,
which is called mining.
And so if you,
if you just have a wallet,
you don't do this,
but if you want to be part of
the bitcoin network as a minor,
what you do is you run on a specialized
computer and it solves this very
difficult problem.
And it's kind of like a competition.
It's like looking for a
magical number is that,
that if you plug it into an equation,
it's,
it's the right number.
It's,
it's almost like a global competition,
like solving a giant Sudoku puzzle.
So everyone's trying,
and then somebody,
every 10 minutes on average finds a
solution and that becomes a new block of
transactions.
And when they find that solution,
they get some bitcoin,
which is new.
Bitcoin is created for the first time.
I'm confused.
Yeah,
I know.
Find a solution for what?
All right.
So basically the idea is everybody's
trying to find a way to create a new block
of transactions,
right?
And in this block they also get
a reward for creating the block.
What is a block of transactions?
It's basically,
um,
it's basically a,
an entry on the ledger.
So,
as I mentioned before,
there's,
um,
there's a way to have,
there's a central transaction ledger where
you can see everybody's transactions.
In order to write on that,
in order to create a new transaction
to the entire network trusts,
you have to solve a
very difficult problem.
Right.
But if you do solve the problem,
you get a reward in bitcoin.
When you say you solved the problem,
is someone physically sitting in front
of their computer trying to solve the
problem of the computers?
The shooter,
yeah.
Okay.
So their computer,
you're using their CPU power.
Yes.
But essentially,
yes,
exactly.
Okay.
So runs in the background,
it's called commercial of work.
You do a,
you're run a program
that does proof of work,
which is basically solving
this difficult problem.
So is this in some way like sort
of similar in fact to how Bitcoin,
how bit torrent works,
where bid corn bid torrent you,
you leave it on like if
you're a sh a file share,
like how bands can spread their music
that way they put their files online,
let people know where there are,
then people seed it
and then they all just,
every,
every bitcoin wallet works like that.
It's like a little bit torrent clients
and it talks to all the wallets and
confined on the,
on the network and communicates.
But there are some
specialized systems which,
which do this computation problem very,
very fast and they're big and noisy and
have lots of fans because it's gotten
very competitive.
So people upgraded their stuff and then
they upgraded it again and then they
upgrade it again.
And it's caused this kind of an
arms race of computing power.
But the basic idea is that you,
you,
you buy a box that has this
ability to solve the problem.
You plug it into the network and it
runs and it chews up electricity and it
glides bitcoin.
A dedicated box to try to help solve
this,
and in the meantime it makes money.
Yeah,
and it makes a bit of money.
And people join in groups
that are called pools,
just like playing a lottery.
Put this while I look.
This guy,
this guy is,
this is his servers.
These are all the Bitcoin solvers,
if I'm not mistaken.
This is a,
yeah,
this is a liquid cool.
A rack system for folks who
haven't seen this photo,
if you're listening to this,
which is the majority of our people,
what are they googling?
Brian?
What's the image?
Coin Mining.
It's the first one.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You have to see this picture folks,
when you get home.
Bitcoin mining,
they have goddamn rooms filled with
computers that they're making bitcoin when
we're in the matrix.
So we're here,
let me just,
Damn Matrix.
Holy Shit.
This is crazy.
There's somebody's house.
So the bitcoin network today is bigger
than the world's top several hundred
super computers combined.
It's the largest single computing
experiment on the Internet ever.
What's using more internet juice,
bitcoin or porn at the moment?
Bitcoin.
That's not possible,
son.
You're talking crazy,
but it's also a,
it's also generating an entire
new economy based on that.
How much prostitution has
been paid for in Bitcoin.
Is that possible?
I have no ideas.
Are you sure?
100% sure that.
Wow.
No,
you're just guessing.
You're not 100% sure.
You're pretty sure you can't say out of
all the people on the road that's sluts
or one uses super peak sloughed.
What if you find the first one today?
All right.
Let me give you an argument
for why that might touch.
That makes sense.
If you're a sex worker,
one of the problems better world have
is you're going to get extorted and
exploited for that money and
you're not going to keep any of it.
With a bitcoin wallet,
you can basically hide that money and
you can also take it in a way that cannot
be taken away from you,
not easily.
So you know there's just take your phone.
Nope,
not so easy.
No.
Because it's backed up and,
right,
exactly.
Yeah.
I mean you're not carrying physical cash.
It's a much safer exchange.
And so there are many reasons why in many
different environments where money is
difficult,
uh,
that bitcoin is successful.
And here's the thing,
bitcoin is very efficient money.
It's a very good system of money.
If you can send money like an
email anywhere in the world will,
yeah,
it's tremendously useful.
And so in places,
and that includes criminal activities
where it's difficult to move money.
Bitcoin is going to be good for that.
Regulate the point because
at the end of the day,
there's another 6 billion of us
want to do good things with it.
And just like on the Internet,
you can use it for crime,
but it gives so much more to humanity.
Of course you can use bitcoin
for crime you can use,
but the reality is US
dollars are used for crime.
The currency in the Washington
prostitution is the most
ridiculous crime ever.
It's so should be legal.
It's so that people can
have sex for free,
but they can't have sex for money.
How come you give him,
give massages for money and massages?
A prostitution.
Okay.
They are,
they might as well be prostitution.
They're awesome.
Don't get me wrong,
I love massages,
but it's fucking prostitution.
The person doesn't want to rub you,
whether it's a guy or a girl,
you want them to rub you,
you give them money,
they rub you.
They even pretend.
They like rubbing you.
They bring you water,
they get you a towel.
They don't give a fuck about that towel.
Bullshit.
Come on man.
That's the,
that's part of the Gig.
Part of the,
that's the part of the prostitution gig.
The idea that in 2014 it's still illegal
to pay someone for sex is so stupid.
Not even handjobs nothing.
No Penis.
Can't touch it.
It's a bad place.
It's a bad place and you can't have
money involved in your bad place.
It's like paying money for crime.
You call it crime.
I just found out.
Yes,
it's being used for prostitution.
Uh,
the first one was September
of this year or last year.
Passion,
VIP and escort agency in England.
Since they had,
now I've accepted bitcoins as payment,
godspeed to you,
passionate Gip in England,
Godspeed to you.
So now we know that kind of crime,
but let's,
let's separate ourselves
from such controversial talk
because this could really
screw people's up.
Their idea of what bitcoin really is.
No,
I mean,
here's the thing.
Bitcoin is not just money,
but when is an invention and what that
invention allows people to do is move
value across the Internet.
And that invention means
you can do bitcoin,
but it also means you can
do a lot of other things.
And bitcoin is an incredible
invention because it,
for the first time,
it completely democratized,
democratizes money.
It's separates money from a function
of power of the state to an individual
exchange between people like it's used
to be when it was shells and feathers,
right?
Or um,
you know,
barter exchange.
But the beauty of it is that it can,
at the moment,
if you think about it,
there is,
let's say a billion people in the
western world who have not just banking
facilities,
but like turbocharged power banking.
They have international transactions.
They can buy stocks on any stock market.
They can do wire transfers,
some of them are credited investors,
et cetera.
The power user of banking,
there's another may be 2 billion people
who have a basic bank account and then
there's the rest of them,
right?
The,
the giant majority of the population on
this planet has very limited access to
banking,
very limited access to
international finance,
to lending,
to capitol,
to uh,
the ability to even change
their money to another currency.
And so bitcoin is so much
more important for them.
I call this the other 6 billion just
keeps the focus on the other 6 billion
because for the billion it might be a fad,
but for the other 6 billion,
this is an opportunity to change the way
we deal with poverty and to change the
way we unite the economic
system of the planet,
which is a whole other
level of compensation.
It will look at bitcoin
and we think of it as
just money,
but it's not just money for the Internet.
Money for the Internet is what it does.
And it does it very well.
But it's the intranet of money and it
allows people at the edge by downloading
just a simple application to join an
economy and then to hold their own money
without any state or corporation.
Being able to steal it from them or
inflated how to value and destroy their
children's future.
It allows them to hold and control
that money and send it to anyone in the
world.
They want to instantly
for very little money.
I mean that's never happened before and
the implications that has for poverty,
for did the developing world for the way
non governmental organizations work is
staggering.
Just take one example.
International remittances at the moment,
500 or so billion dollars cent
every year from the first world,
two countries in the developing world,
right.
And out of that money,
74 billion gets spent in fees,
fees as high as 30 or 40% in fact,
the poor of the country,
the higher the percentage
of fee you have to pay.
So Somalia and my migrants in
the u s who sending $100 home,
only 70 gets to the,
to the,
to the wife or the brother back home or
the husband back home and the rest gets
chewed out by the money
transfer companies.
Now we give the developed world 150 or
so billion and then we to the richest and
hope it trickles down and then we
take 74 billion from the poorest.
What if we could change that?
What if we could enable bitcoin
remittances and international payments and
redeliver that 74 billion of their
money and allow them to send that money
directly home without paying that fee?
That changes the lives
of a billion people.
Wow.
So you envisioned bitcoin as
being a universal currency.
Absolutely.
It already is.
Will it absorb the dollar or the,
will the dollar go away with a
doll coexist along with bitcoin?
Like what is your hope for this?
Well,
I mean I think that like many disruptive
technologies is going to change the
power balance.
It's not that the dollar goes
away of the banking system,
goes away,
it just has less power and less relevance
in a new world where people control
their own money and can
send it to each other.
So ultimately the grand
hope is that the money,
the dollar that we see
today becomes in the future.
Much like the written letter,
no fucking need it anymore.
You can send emails,
you send someone a text message,
you have to get on a fucking pony and
carry your mail over to another state.
Yes.
And the thing is,
the dollar again is the
world reserve currency.
And there's only one of it.
Now are there 193 other currencies that,
that some of them may
end up getting replaced?
Uh,
some of them may end up even
converting into cryptocurrencies.
Have a nation states,
you know,
like,
I don't know,
Thailand coin,
why not?
Or Fed coin if we're doing it here.
But the point is that we can't judge
bitcoin on the standard of the most
comfortable world reserve currency.
That's the most stable currents we
have to look at the rest of the world.
And see what their currencies are like.
And in many cars,
countries,
the currency is worth less than goat shit
because you can burn goat shed longer
than you can burn these bundles of
paper money that doesn't burn very well,
you know,
and in in those countries,
this is not a matter of shopping.
This is a matter of of the future of
their children and it's a matter of
development.
Wow,
that's,
that's really fascinating.
It's,
it's one of the concerns
as far as security.
What are the concerns as far as
if someone steals your bitcoins,
is there any sort of a regulatory
body that can determine whether or not
someone's computer or phones been hacked
into and their big bitcoin's had been
stolen?
I mean I have,
has that become an issue yet
or is that a potential issue?
It is a potential issue and it
has become an issue and yeah,
people have had their bitcoin stolen.
You,
how has that happened?
What is their computer gets hacked and
then they have a password on the account,
but they don't have like,
um,
you know,
one of the things you can do very easily
is set up what's called two factor
authentication.
So every time you tried to
use your bitcoin wallet,
it sends you a little text message and
you have to enter the secret code like
you do with your bank height.
Slightly higher on the socio
computer's been hacked.
They don't get the text messages,
they can't easily get into your account.
What does that,
that article you just brought up,
Brian,
this is the latest hack.
I know that Bitcoin has
been hacked a few times,
but this last one was
one point $2 million.
And there's an article on wired called
1.2 million hacks shows why you should
never store bitcoins on the Internet.
Uh,
what,
what happens to something like that?
That they just lost this,
right?
There's no,
there's no getting this back.
And,
and is there somebody that
like a group of people that um,
that you think is responsible for this or?
Well,
no,
I mean there's always been a,
a thriving hacker underground that a,
that he uses the most
efficient way to steal money.
And so they stole money from targets by
compromising all of those credit cards
just a few weeks ago.
And that affected her a lot more
people than any of these thefts.
And you know that they're going
to go after wherever the money is.
And if the efficient money is bitcoin,
they're going to go after bitcoin too.
But here's the trick,
because this money is controlled through
mathematical security and because it's
programmable,
we can actually create new ways of
securing money so we can innovate,
whether it's the paper
wallet example I gave you,
where you can create a physical copy
that you can secure old style in a safe
deposit box,
whether it's using
multisignature transactions,
where for example,
the money is locked and it takes,
uh,
two keys or three keys to unlock it.
So for example,
you can have a backup company
that provides the second key.
And so if you lose the primary key,
you could use the secondary key.
You can do digital backups,
you can do,
you can do time locks,
you can do all kinds of things now with
money because it's programmable that
allow you to create new
ways of securing it.
So it's still very early,
early days.
Um,
you know,
some,
some people who don't take care put too
much of their bitcoin in one place and
yeah,
that's not a very good idea.
They have weak passwords.
So in this happened,
when these people lost
1.2 million in Bitcoin,
there's no bringing that back.
There's no tracing it.
There's no find out where it went or
their social securities and these bitcoins
or numbers rather than
these bitcoins that nope,
like dollar bills,
you know,
they'd trace like back
it's cash.
No,
it's because it's digital.
I mean,
this is one of the key,
um,
one of the key controls in the system is
that it's like teleporting the digital
cash and you know,
once it,
it's not on your Tele
Porter pad and it's gone,
you just hope the other teleporter
we'll send it back to you.
Cause otherwise it's gone.
I mean it's digital cash.
It can go very easily
because it flows very easily.
Um,
so what we're doing at the moment is
developing new security techniques to make
it both harder to steal in the,
in the first place to have
backups so that you can,
um,
so they couldn't get back if a,
if a key stolen before it's used and
there's all kinds of things we can do to
make this better.
It's still early days.
There was a story about that guy who
left his bitcoin on his hard drive and
tossed it out accidentally
and it's worth $9 million.
Right.
I'm sure you're aware of that story.
Yeah.
This was in,
uh,
this was,
an England and throughout the,
actually all that happened is that a
lot of people showed up at the local
landfill with a,
with metal detectors.
So a lot of people were looking
for this treasure hunters.
Again,
we're trying to steal it.
Well,
digital treasure hunting
is going to be a thing,
a part of our future.
Yeah.
So you've got,
people are going to like
find old hard drives.
When my 2013 and I looked
for bitcoins on them,
well I love stories like this.
I was on Reddit the other day and
I was reading this great story.
This student who said,
you know,
back in 2010 I did some bitcoin mining
on my laptop and I just found that wallet
and it says,
I have 917 bitcoin.
Am I rich or am I missing something
because this would really change my life.
I've got student loans and the guy had,
you know,
at the time it was a $900,000 worth of
bitcoin that he had found from a laptop.
He left laying around in
2010 and did some mining,
and that story is great
and it's happened many,
many times.
So did it,
that guy sell that and become
like almost a millionaire.
Yup.
That's insane.
And this was a student who was like,
I'm having trouble with my student loans.
You know,
this could really help me.
Am I too am I?
He couldn't believe it.
He was like,
I might see this wrong.
That's from mining.
So,
okay,
let's,
let's
good crazy talking monkey studios here.
We decided to start a mining up.
Don't,
don't,
don't know.
I mean it's the high
trying to win $1 million.
It's like,
I'm sorry,
which tells me we don't know so well,
I'll sign.
I had it figured out.
So the,
the,
the reason people have been successful
with bitcoin is because they got
interested in the technology went only
a few thousand people knew about it and
when they got involved,
at that point,
bitcoins were worth like a hundredth of
a penny or a thousandth of a penny and
now they're worth a $2.
So if you ended up mining some,
then even if you only mind a few,
you know,
plus it was a lot easier to mind then
because over time the network adjust the
difficulty.
So the more people trying,
the harder it gets.
So the network is autonomous,
there's no centralized server,
there's no central anything.
It's,
it's a series of rules that everybody
follows and it's hard to grasp at first
because we've never seen this
type of distributed organization.
And is there any organization
whatsoever as far as like a CEO,
Doris,
does that money go then every
time the transaction goes?
Is it good just Atashi Nakamoto?
No,
no,
no.
If they even exist,
there's not even a real picture of him
anywhere on the Internet and no one's
actually ever confirmed his identity.
So it could be just the government
or anonymous.
It's an invisible hacker visit,
physically invisible.
So all of the people who are
doing the mining who have the,
the,
the hardware in a,
using it to mine for Bitcoin,
what they do is they secure the network
by running this very hard problem.
They prevent anyone else from cheating
because in order to essentially they end
up voting on every block together with
this enormous computing power and that
enormous computing power means no one
can falsify the block because they would
have to do that much computing
power to falsify the the ledger,
right?
So if you can't falsify it without doing
enormous amounts of computing power,
but if you do enormous amounts of
computing power that you get a reward and
bitcoin while you're going to try and win
the game rather than cheat cheating is
extremely difficult and not rewarding.
Whereas participating is rewarding.
I see.
Right.
So all of these miners are working
and what they do is they verify the
transactions and they
secure the entire network,
which actually if you look at it
on the grand scheme of things,
is a lot cheaper than guards and armored
trucks and alarm companies and faults
and data centers and fraud
prevention center is,
and all of those things that we have
in our traditional payment system,
it's actually a lot cheaper to do it
by proving you're doing all of this
computation for the network security.
Now they collect fees.
So when they verify a block,
the person who manages the verify at
first by finding this little magic number,
the solution to the problem,
I'll explain that in a second,
collects the fees that are in the block.
So all of the transactions
that get verified.
Then the next 10 minutes,
the miner who finds that block will
collect all of the little fees.
40 cents here,
40 cents they are 40 cents there.
It's about 40 40 cents to send a simple
transaction right now and they'll also
get a reward of 25 bitcoin and then
everyone will start the race again to,
to verify the next block of transactions
for the next 10 minutes of spending.
And the first one to find the
solution wins gets the reward,
gets the fees and they
all start competing again.
But you don't know who's going to win it.
And the enormous amount of computation
that goes into its ensures that no one
can cheat.
Even if you put together the 600 most
powerful supercomputers in the world,
you would not be able to get to
to beat the system right now.
What a fascinating element to be
added to the idea of the economy.
This,
this idea of the unified
group of computers working
on ever increasingly complex
computations.
So the scientific term for it
is a consensus assets ledger,
which means it's a lighter or
list of transactions about assets.
In this case,
bitcoin that's based on consensus on
agreement and the agreement is reached by
everyone voting with
their computing power.
And because there's so much of it,
you can't cheat the election.
Now,
when you said that there have been other
attempts at a new type of currency that
had been shut down by the
current banking system,
that was because they had a place where
they had centralized servers exactly
operated or the centralized service
or a centralized organization
or a centralized something.
What did they do to stop it?
That movie?
Is there any legality issues when it
comes to doing something like this or
creating a new type of currency?
Oh sure.
Oh,
there's this,
there's an enormous legality issues.
I mean the banking system
has this fortress wall of
regulations around it that
acts partly supposedly to protect
consumers from misbehaving banks but also
serves very well to prevent competition
from small banks because it's very
expensive to do to,
you know,
pass all the tests.
Right,
right.
Say keeps the RAF the rabble out,
but uh,
you know,
then a lot of the criminals end up
being inside this whole system here.
Here's the thing that,
that whole regulatory system comes down
hard on people who had decided to want
to create their own currency.
And the Nice thing about bitcoin
is that there is no one there.
I mean,
basically in agreement when
you say comes down hard,
like in what manner?
Like how,
how would they come down hard?
Like let's say you just asset forfeiture,
seizures,
lawsuits,
a money laundering charges,
all kinds of things like that.
And this is because you're not
doing things by regulation,
is that what you're saying?
Well,
it has happened that way in the past.
So you no matter what,
what if you decide to create your own
currency and you have an actual business
and you were a centralized business
that essentially be centralized.
Business is responsible for following all
of the government standards on banking
100% across the board.
And if you don't,
that's where money laundering charges,
larceny and a lot of different
charges get brought up is that,
that's what goes on now that's avoided
somehow or another through bitcoin
because of the voided.
It's simply the bitcoin is a
completely decentralized system.
It works based on math.
So there is no,
there's no one running bitcoin.
It was an invention just like someone
invented electricity than we all learned
how it worked and we
all ended up using it.
But does it matter who you know,
invented the electricity
that makes us light work?
No.
Bitcoin is like that.
It's a standard.
It's an idea and it runs by people
participating in the network.
So there's nothing,
there is no central location,
there's no company behind it,
there's no leader,
there's nothing.
It's a decentralized,
it's just like no one runs the Internet.
So if you say,
I don't want the Internet to do this,
who are
you gonna sue?
It's a global network.
Yeah.
I mean what Al Gore Al
Gore for inventing it.
Why it's,
well that's one of the reasons to Toshi
Nakamoto disappeared because he was
smart enough to know that uh,
you know,
smearing him would affect bitcoin but
couldn't he could since he programmed
everything,
have access to everybody's
money if he wanted to know.
So let me explain that.
The software itself is so
called open source software.
That means that it's a recipe
of code that implements the,
the big coin agreement according
to the network standards.
And you can write your own,
I mean if you don't want to run that
software you can write a version of it.
In fact,
there are five or six different,
um,
you know,
fully compliant versions that
can participate in the network.
And even if you take the basic one
that started with him writing it,
but since has involved in a community
project with lots of people writing code,
you know,
just like the intranet,
it,
you just agree to play by the rules.
And then you can read the code and
you can see exactly what happens.
There is no controls in there.
There's no magic secret keys.
You can see how it works.
What do you,
what are you saying?
Hold on a second.
There's five or six
different types of bitcoin.
There's,
there's five or six
different programs that can,
that can do the full bitcoin,
uh,
language on the bitcoin network.
Five or six different versions,
but they all speak bitcoin
so it doesn't matter.
But what are they doing
differently than the other ones?
Just um,
different ways,
different programming languages,
different ways of implementing them.
Some are more efficient in some ways.
Some are more efficient than the others,
but they don't do anything
different in terms of bitcoin.
So there's just like,
there are lots of different internet
routers and they all speak TCP Ip on the
internets and you know,
Cisco makes some [inaudible] juniper
networks make some others in HP makes them
others,
but they all speak the same.
I see.
So there's no concern whatsoever.
There's any security openings because of
the fact that these guys are producing
their own software.
That communicates in big,
right?
Because the trust is based on computation,
not taxes.
So this is a key thing to realize all of
our payment systems and banking systems
up to now keep trust in the
system by keeping people out,
by controlling very carefully
who connects to the network.
And that means the network
is always very small.
In bitcoin,
all of the trust is done
by this joint computation,
right?
And so who talks the network doesn't
matter because the network is trusted and
safe regardless of what you try to send
to it or receive from it or how you
interpret it because there's no center.
So this has radical implications because
that means you can let anyone talk to
the network or rather you can let everyone
talk to the network and everyone can
be a bank on that network
and everyone can send wires,
transfers on that network power
of a bank on your smartphone.
And as long as it speaks to the bitcoin
language and understands it with the
rest of the network,
you don't need to trust,
you know it,
that that
application is running.
The trust happens in the
transactions in the network,
you can't cheat no matter what you do.
Right?
So what is the motivation
to write a new software?
What does the mode
fish,
it's like there are different
pieces that all run windows.
There's you know,
different clients that all run picc line.
I see.
So they just have to sit at decided to
run their own program that that speaks
bitcoin but it participates
in the exact same fashion.
Right?
You have a chrome browser or you have
a Firefox browser or why there too,
right?
Same thing.
Okay.
In fact it's very similar or
like a bit torrent client.
There are three different versions,
but they all speak bitterns and
your brows is all speak http,
the hypertext transfer protocol.
So no matter what website you go to,
and there are lots of websites,
programs that made by different companies
that speak the server side of the web.
You know,
there's lots of different versions.
But what matters is the
common language they speak.
And bitcoin is like that.
It's a common language,
a protocol or standard.
And that means that no matter
what you attached to the network,
whether it's a a wallet
that's written for Androids,
a wallet that's written for Iphone or
a wallet that's fancier or a wallet
that's,
that's more geeky.
All of these will speak Bitcoin to the
network and we'll work with a system and
the trust is in the network.
Now,
when we were talking earlier about the,
if you had a centralized location,
centralized server that can be shut down
by the banks and they could charge you
with all these crimes,
is there any concern legally speaking
that if you were a person who has all your
money in bitcoin that maybe one day the
government could come along and say,
bitcoin is not a valid currency,
it's illegal to use using it as
a crime and we find it on you,
we're going to take it from you
and we're going to arrest you?
Well,
actually,
yeah.
Government has already said that bitcoin
is legal and that users using bitcoin
are are doing perfectly legal business.
Can you pay taxes in Bitcoin?
I'm not directly,
no.
You'd have to convert it to dollars,
but as a company that will take your
bitcoin and pay the taxes for you.
Bingo.
So,
um,
uh,
back in April,
the fin cen,
which is the financial
crimes enforcement network,
uh,
created a memorandum where it
explains how we treat bitcoin.
And it said,
you know,
if you're just an individual using
bitcoin to buy and sell things,
great.
It's just like anything else you,
you're going to pay,
uh,
you know you're going
to pay your transaction.
And that's it.
If you're someone who
makes a living in Bitcoin,
you pay income tax.
And if you're someone
who's mining on Bitcoin,
you pay income tax on those bitcoins.
So if you're an investor,
you pay capital gains.
It's treated just like any other currency.
So if you make your living off Bitcoin,
that's how you get paid.
You convert that to dollars,
then you pay a percentage in dollars.
Is that what you should do?
You convert like how much you made in
Bitcoin coin in the year and what that
would be in dollar bills and
then pay the percentage on that.
Right.
But I mean that's not different
from what I did before.
When I got paid in euros.
I mean occasionally I get a
paycheck from a customer in Europe.
They're going to pay me in euro's,
right?
What do you do?
You convert it to dollars.
You mark the rates at which they paid you,
you know,
you invoiced them,
they paid you in euros,
you mark what rate it was,
and then you put it on
the tax return as income.
People are notoriously bad about
reporting income when you know,
when it's independent,
when they're not being
taxed by their employer,
when it's not coming directly
out of their paycheck.
Comedians are terrible about that.
I know so many comedians that have had
like serious IRS problems because of
that.
I would think that that sort of issue
would arise with bitcoin where people are
responsible for paying taxes
on these and they don't.
I mean,
how much,
how much of an issue is that and how
much of a criminality issue could that
become?
Well,
I I think has al Capone found out there
was one thing you can too in the u s and
that's not pay your taxes.
They might get,
they might not get you for anything else.
You pull it up,
right.
I keep pulling up these orders,
I pay my taxes and uh,
and if you earn money in Bitcoin,
you pay your taxes on
Bitcoin is simple as death.
And if you think you can get
away with not doing that,
then you'll find out like many people
before you that the IRS will come,
will audit you and you will
end up paying a lot more.
Yeah.
Even if you want to pay them
back and agree to pay them back,
they still put you in jail.
So yeah,
I don't think you need to sit in a cage
for a little while and think about what
you did.
I mean,
the,
that would simply be a
monumentally stupid sink to do,
uh,
to think that somehow that would protect.
No,
I mean they're going to track down
your accounts just as effectively with
bitcoin as they deal with other things.
They're not stupid.
What are these articles
you keep pulling up?
Brian,
just keep on finding new things
about different news reports.
Like this was a four hours ago where
two guys have been arrested a major,
a prominent players in
the bitcoin universe.
Charles Sherman was arrested by federal
prosecutors on Sunday and accused of
helping grease the wheels
for drug transactions,
you know,
uh,
using bitcoins and uh,
Mr Shrem was also the founder and chief
executive of popular website called bit
instant.
We're bitcoins could be
bought using dollars.
And so what it seems like there's a
lot of people getting arrested though.
There was another guy that I flashed
up earlier that was arrested.
It seems like there's a lot of shady
stuff going on in this universe right now.
Honestly,
that's the only reason I never
went and got into bitcoins.
You don't feel nervous about all these
like recent news things at all or cause
you seem very pro like I,
I'm not worried about it at all.
Stated playstation that people are not
going to stop going online and shopping
on amazon.com of Amazon gets hacked.
What you're dealing with is a
few people that are scumbags,
that are operating in this
a truly revolutionary system
that is very beneficial.
Yeah.
But this is like hitting send counselors.
There's bank,
this is like robbing a bank,
you know.
Well,
no,
in this whole,
so here's my perspective.
Um,
bitcoin is a,
technology is
powerful and is being used by school
teachers to manage a PTA groups.
It's been used by churches to manage
tithing and their collection plates.
And there are clubs and it's also being
used by criminals occasionally to do
crimes just like any other currency.
In fact,
the,
the point is that compared to
another currency like the dollar,
uh,
you know,
the,
the money laundering that
happens with a dollar,
I mean,
HSBC was found and convicted
under consent agreements,
I think for $17 billion of money
laundering with the worst Mexican cartels.
And they got a minor fine
and no one went to jail.
And what Cocoavia was money laundering,
hundreds of billions of dollars with,
uh,
with,
various drug cartels in Asia.
And again,
nothing happened.
So let's not pretend that suddenly
bitcoin is like this criminal,
uh,
situation.
It's not,
it just represents just like the Internet
represents society and you get the
whole spectrum.
Bitcoin as a currency can be used for
economic activity and that means the whole
spectrum.
And you'll have a small subset who are
people who take advantage and then you
have the vast majority.
Increasingly now it's
getting more mainstream.
I see the possibility of being able to
do exciting new things with money that
weren't possible before and,
and to enable new forms of commerce.
You know,
there are hundreds of startups that
are innovating with new forms of,
for example,
how to do settlement and escrow on a real
estate transaction and not spend 2% on
that but do it with
bitcoin much more safely,
much more effectively.
Companies that are working on doing
charitable foundations based on Bitcoin
endowments,
charities that are working
to do remittances to foreign
countries to help the
poor people.
You know,
all kinds of activities are happening.
But what is the primary
focus of the media?
It is to generate page views and you know,
portraying the sensationalist
stuff always wins out.
So there's a lot more to bitcoin.
Don't get fooled by the fact that,
you know,
some,
some things are emphasized
as if that's the be all.
And Adult Ed Coyle was certainly
some things are emphasized,
but those are legitimate stories.
I mean,
that was a legitimate story that
the stores are arrested for.
You can't judge the media on
reporting legitimate crimes.
No,
I don't think that's the,
that's the issue.
The problem is,
you know,
you get a lot more of that than,
than is actually occurring and
you get a lot less of the stuff.
That's really interesting
and important in my view.
The positive stories.
Positive stories.
Exactly.
And you know,
the way I look at Bitcoin,
I think about the possibility
you can create jobs.
I look at it as a
technological innovation.
I look at it as an engine for
growth in a stagnant economy,
you know,
so,
so those are the things
that stick in my mind.
Jobs,
innovation and growth.
Not,
you know,
the
fact that,
uh,
some bad dude used
bitcoin to do bad things.
Your,
your example of the bank that was
laundering money with the drug cartels is
absolutely perfect because that
barely got a peep out of people.
And that was a very recent decision.
And you know,
I mean,
I saw some outrage from
a few Twitter users.
I literally,
I've read the story and
my mouth was hanging open.
I was like,
how could they get away with
that and just get a fine,
like they dealt with murderers and they
laundered their drug money and they did
it for a long time and
they made a lot of money.
Yeah.
And they just got a slap
wasn't even up to the par
of the money they made.
That's the shocking thing.
It's not even covering
the profits they lost,
which basically rewards and says,
yeah,
go ahead,
do it again.
You made a great return
on that investment.
There's a real issue with this whole
Mexican drug war is that there's so much
money to be made and being a part of
it and it leaves so many holes open for
corruption.
And even legal corruption,
like this type of stuff where it's,
it's they do something,
they get fined by
whatever regulatory body,
but yet they're still in business.
They're still,
they're enacting in the
profit on that decision,
encouraging,
literally encouraging people to continue
to do business with illegal groups like
that.
If you can make that kind of profit,
which you know,
there's a real issue in this country,
a massive amount of distrust of law
enforcement and there's a big part of that
becomes,
uh,
it comes out of the war on drugs.
It comes out of the war
on nicknamed the drug.
You know,
whether it's cocaine or whether all these
different people that are struggling
to keep things illegal are pumping up
all these businesses that sell these
illegal drugs because there's
this massive demand for it.
So when you see a war on drugs,
w w what's you're seeing is,
is an engine to generate money for crime.
That's all it is.
People are not going to stop
altering their consciousness,
but you are ensuring that the people that
are profiting off of that are going to
be criminals.
And then it leaves the door
open for people who are in,
in actual law enforcement to see these
loopholes and see these these ways.
They could skim a little money to
take a little bit home for themselves.
And next thing you know,
you got corruption and next thing you go,
you got bankers going,
listen,
I can guarantee you the worst going to
happen is we're going to get a fine if I
was going to be little and we're
going to make a fuck load of money.
And these guys Pedro's coming
over and he's got a donkey cart.
Well this,
this is the best part of the story in,
in one of these bank,
uh,
situations where they had these branches
and Mexico and they were putting
literally millions of
dollars in suitcases,
a stake in them through the teller window.
They actually ended up designing and
mass manufacturing suitcases that fits
through the slot because they
were doing it every single day.
So they had a teller window slot fitting
briefcase so they could stuff that cash
through
and no one went to jail.
Wow,
that's amazing.
So,
you know,
I mean,
we can talk about money
all day and some money.
We'll create situations for
people to take advantage.
Absolutely.
Well it does the way with guns,
it's good.
Does that we were everything.
I mean that's that whole,
um,
that fast and furious investigation that
you know about that there was a worthy
whatever government agency was selling
arms to Mexican drug dealers so that they
can quote unquote track the guns.
You know?
And it's ridiculous because those guns
actually got used for killing American
service members,
American,
the people that were
involved in border patrol,
people that were involved
in law enforcement,
a lot of these,
uh,
these guns wound up being used to
actually kill Americans more than one.
And
the idea behind it is so preposterous.
The idea that you're going to sell weapons
to criminals so that you could track
where these weapons go.
Like,
no,
that's a fucking terrible idea.
These are the people that
are in charge of deciding,
you know,
what kind of laws get enforced and what
w what atmosphere of law enforcement
this,
this country has.
And when you see things like that,
it's so frustrating and confusing
because it seems almost like a Palladian
crime.
Like someone's solds sold some guns to
these Mexican drug lords and they did it
under the guise of this crazy operation.
We're just going to sell them guns
and keep an eye on them that way.
We'll track them and then we're
going to get them that way.
You're giving them guns
like that's what they want.
That's what they need to perform crimes.
You're giving them tools.
It's like a guy who's a fucking carpenter.
You're giving them a saw and a hammer.
You're giving it to him and you're
literally telling them to go use them.
I mean,
that's essentially what you're
doing and you're profiting off that.
How was,
how were you not in jail for selling guns?
How do you,
how can you say that?
That was a,
uh,
an idea,
a plan that you had?
I mean,
it's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable and it's in,
it's impossible to,
to read those stories and,
and,
and understand how we could ever trust
the people that are in charge of,
of,
of running this country.
If this is something
you're capable of doing,
how the fuck can anybody trust you?
How could anybody ever take
your leadership seriously
if this is what you do?
This is madness.
Well,
I mean that's one of the reasons
that I think a lot of people are also
passionate about Bitcoin
is that they've realized,
especially since 2008 that these same
people cannot be trusted to run the money
system.
And we've seen now for the last,
for example,
five years,
the Fed has been printing between 85
now tapered down to about $70 billion a
month and giving it as corporate welfare
and direct subsidies to the banks.
So we didn't get a stimulus,
but they are continuing for five years
now to remain solvent based on $70
billion a month.
That's $1 trillion a year,
almost in dollars generated by the Fed.
Most people don't even
know this is happening.
These little people running our,
and what it means is
that you go out to use your dollars at
the store and suddenly you can buy a lot
less bread and a lot less
milk and a lot fewer eggs.
But then the teak items
out of the inflation index.
So it looks like there is no inflation.
Where's anybody who's trying to spend
their dollars knows that things are
getting harder and harder and harder,
right?
These are the people running our money.
So bitcoin offers an alternative approach,
which says let's trust math.
Let's trust that the system
runs based on a rule,
a simple mathematical role.
And everybody agrees that that is the
rule by which money is created and no one
can monkey with it.
And,
and that's the beauty of it
because if you know the rules,
it reduces the uncertainty,
it reduces the risk.
And when you have a simple system where
people can interact with each other and
exchange money based on
simple mathematic rules,
that system's going to do quite well
because people no longer trust their
governments even here.
And it's much worse everywhere else.
Do you think that these issues that we
have with the financial system and the
law enforcement system are sort of
magnified by the solution of Bitcoin,
that this being the internet of money
that really we need an internet of law
enforcement.
We need an internet of,
of,
of uh,
regulations.
We need what we all agree on.
We don't need what's been
stuffed down our throat.
We need what we agree on by consensus
based on the information that's currently
available,
which is what we would get if we didn't
have some sort of a centralized group
that's in charge of deciding
what's legal and not legal,
how things are enforced,
how things are done,
how,
how laws are,
are,
are created.
Let's talk about smart law and smart
contracts cause this is a perfect
opportunity.
Bitcoin,
the underlying invention,
the blockchain asset
ledger as it's called,
basically allows people to agree on
who owns Watson to resolve differences
through this computation.
But the basic thing that means is that
you can start doing smart contracts.
That means that you can put contracts
into the system and then they either get
executed because the conditions are met
or they do not based on mathematics.
So you could say,
for example,
I'm going to have,
instead of having a deed to my car,
the trench does with the TM fee,
I'm going to have a digital deed that's
on the bitcoin network and when someone
pays me the money to buy that car,
that transaction is married to
the deed transferring to them.
And the verification happens
by the bitcoin network,
which I trust based on
distributed consensus.
No one at the center,
no one monkeying with the rules.
So now you can start doing contracts
and using the same basic mathematics to
fully resolve contracts.
You could have,
for example,
a parent setting up a number
of transactions in the
blockchain and the bitcoin
network is that send money to their kids
in two decades when they're going to be
18 or 20 or 21 right?
So like a trust fund or a will and you
could write that off as a contract and
then executed on the bitcoin
network and the no one can stop it.
No one can reverse it.
No one can invalidate it.
That's pretty powerful stuff.
It allows people to have
contracts between them,
between each other that are adjudicated,
if you like,
by the bitcoin network based
on the mathematical rules.
And how would these things be enforced
if they had to be in a court of law,
would that ever be an option?
Would they ever be
considered legally binding?
Well simple.
The simple matter is that the transaction
goes through or the transaction does
not go through the transaction as either
valid because you presented the right
keys or it is not valid.
And once the transaction has gone through,
it's gone through.
I mean that's the simple
way the network works.
So you know,
adjudication is something that you
then have to deal with after the fact.
Like if a,
if a,
if a parent put a transaction in
the bitcoin network that gave,
uh,
you know,
money to their kid as part of a
will is that can't be contested.
When that kid presents the key,
that transaction goes through.
Don,
the network has agreed that
that money has transferred,
it's transferred.
So it doesn't need a judge's
written consent or it doesn't need
no,
it's mathematical rules instead without,
you know the,
the,
the benefit of this is that instead of
relying on the ambiguity of language,
which is the basis of
most law for many things,
you will have to,
but for some simple things like doing
an escrow for a house or you know,
buying a car or transferring
property or doing a trust or a will,
you could simply a convert those legal
contracts into bitcoin transactions that
then get executed under a certain set of
rules and suddenly you've got a form of
smart law,
self executing law that happens based on
the bitcoin network's ability to agree
on what's true.
It's fascinating to think that this could
be one step in an ultimate revamping
of our society and the revamping of our
society based on the Internet and that
if bitcoin or and things like Bitcoin,
these peer used groups,
these groups of,
you know,
many people agreeing on a standard
and a subscribing to a system,
if that can happen with this,
they can start happening with a lot
of things could start happening with
education.
It can start happening with,
you know,
w w with even with law enforcement,
the idea of community law enforcement or,
or figuring out some way to a fun private
law enforcement or private contractors
based on a situation like this.
So for,
for the biggest part of human history,
a lot of the most difficult problems like
communicating at distances or agreeing
with lots of different
people simply didn't scale.
And because you couldn't
scale solutions to those,
we built hierarchal
institutions to solve them.
Representative democracy,
we built councils and committees
to solve decision making.
We built banks and central banks,
uh,
in order to solve issuance of
currency and other things like that.
And we built hierarchal
media organizations because
we needed a single voice to
tell us what to think.
And then gradually we're
seeing the solutions that
are decentralized that solve
the problem without a hierarchal
organization and that scale.
So the Internet was the first
decentralized communications
that scales to the
whole planet.
And so suddenly all of the hierarchal
solutions for communication are no longer
necessary.
They solve a problem that doesn't exist.
The problem of it being difficult to
transmit information across a continent or
across the globe.
Once our problem goes away,
the institution's built to solve it.
New Systems,
large entertainment and
marketing organizations to,
you know,
create single output products.
All of those are no longer necessary.
And the choice blossoms.
Bitcoin is simply the same concept of
decentralization but applied to money.
And one of the interesting things is the
bitcoin at its core works on the fact
that you can decentralize
voting and do voting at scale.
And the voting that's happening right
now is the voting to agree on who has the
bitcoin.
But you could do voting
for other things like
you know,
stocks,
bonds,
global lotteries,
national elections and things like that.
When you say
voting is to see who has the bitcoins.
So when,
when essentially the,
uh,
the mining process,
the verifies each block of transaction
and secure set is like a giant votes in
election that happens every 10 minutes.
And by looking at the transactions,
you can tell who has the bitcoin.
If the entire network has said,
Andrea sent Joe a bitcoin and
that's been verified by the network,
then everyone trusts Joe has a bitcoin
and will be willing to accept that
bitcoin and payment for something.
Right?
So essentially the,
you have this every 10 minutes you have
this consensus where the entire network
agrees on all of the
transactions that have happened,
who has waltz,
what's going on on the system,
the ability to add,
have massive scale.
Have everyone agree on what the truth is?
That is the core invention behind bitcoin
does that makes currency possible,
but it also makes other things possible,
including elections.
So you can do some pretty incredible
things because what you've done is you've
decentralized decision making,
the Internet decentralized communications.
Bitcoin is decentralizing money,
but at its core is an invention that
decentralizes decisionmaking yeah,
no.
What are the concerns as far as bitcoin
getting shut down and what repercussions
or what,
what kind of blow back,
if any,
have you guys received
the people that are,
uh,
in charge of,
you know,
spreading of this bitcoin
evangelists as it were?
I mean,
is,
is there any repercussions or
any blow back or is there any,
nope,
nothing so far.
No.
I mean,
you know,
there's,
there's a little misunderstanding
that happen every now and then and,
uh,
you know,
um,
people at first who don't
understand the technology sometimes,
um,
sit down and have conversations
to understand it better.
But,
you know,
the,
the point is that at the moment,
bitcoin is legal to use and it's not just
legal to use in the u s but it's legal
to use in pretty much every country,
um,
for individuals.
Certainly,
I think,
I don't think any country has bandit
or has even attempted to ban it.
Um,
bitcoin is money as a piece of content
that you can send on the Internet.
So if you,
even if you wanted to ban it,
who would be relatively difficult to do
that without shutting down the Internet?
So that's one thing to put out there.
But the point is a,
nobody's trying to ban bitcoin.
Nobody's trying to shut us down.
I think especially in the u s and
especially among senior lawmakers like the
Senate who had hearings,
uh,
recently about Bitcoin,
the prevailing attitude is,
look,
this is generating growth
is generating jobs.
It's a huge innovation.
And,
um,
we see that it's being used at a very
broad manner can change a lot of things.
You know,
maybe we should take a
wait and see approach.
Uh,
and the price went up quite
dramatically after they said that.
But the general attitude is most,
most politicians are far more interested
in the possibility that this might
generate growth and also
jobs and as a result,
votes and campaign finance
money than they are about,
you know,
beating this down because it's
going to affect different interests.
So there's still open to it.
And I think we've got a tremendous
opportunity to educate people about all of
the incredible things we can do and also
highlight the fact that this bitcoin
economy just in the last
year has generated thousands
of jobs in an environment
where we have economic stagnation.
We've got this bloom of
innovation and technology,
uh,
much like the first burst of
the Internet and you know,
that's a tremendous thing.
You don't want to squash that just
because of a misunderstanding.
Do you think that there's a lack of blow
back because the people in the powers
of be just having considered bitcoin to
be a threat yet because we'll be talking
about like politicians not acting
to try to the sound set to service.
They're the people that get
him in the office a little.
The little the lobbyists or special
interest groups that would have you like
that's just because they haven't been
contacted by those people to try to do
something about bitcoin.
I think even the banks are ambivalent on
this because while it may be disruptive
to some of their banking practices,
it is also one of the most interesting
and innovative things to happen in
finance in the last hundred years.
And so I think a lot of banks
are smart enough to say,
look,
we were good at technology.
Um,
we know money,
we've got branches,
we've got customers,
we've got marketing,
we've got brands,
we know how to do security.
We could really make a good deal with
this bit coin thing and use it and make
some really interesting financial things.
So there's this mixed bag,
just like,
you know,
and I'll bring the same example.
When entertainment companies were
first face with the possibility of MP3,
yes.
Some people were like,
oh my God,
this is going to destroy everything.
Music will die.
Right.
Which is the same they've said
with every previous technology,
you're were right though.
Uh,
but,
but no,
they weren't because,
right.
But the,
the point is that since then,
the number of genres
and number of artists,
the number of the amount
of music has exploded.
Um,
people get a broader range
of music than ever before.
And mp3s have created so much good
in the entertainment industry,
so much more than damage.
Right?
And I think even in banking environments,
they recognize that with
bitcoin there's this mixed bag,
which is that the good
far outweighs the bad.
And even in a business that's going to
get disrupted as banking will be just
like entertainment and telephone
companies were disrupted by the Internet.
Um,
those that are smart can take advantage
and they can build something good with
this and they're going to
lose some power and leverage,
but they can make some
good money out of this.
So I don't think any was out
to get bitcoin right now.
Right.
I think people are,
are commonly evaluating it's,
and,
and thinking about what
opportunities it can bring.
And I think that's the best approach.
Would you pull up,
uh,
about the taxes?
Because I guess there's this
whole thing going on that people,
uh,
need to claim the,
the,
the stuff that the purchases or the
money that they get from bitcoin on your
taxes,
but the IRS hasn't said how to do it yet.
Well,
I,
I mean,
I've discussed this with my
accountant and they gave me a pretty
straightforward,
a formula.
If I earn income on Bitcoin,
I'm mark how many dollars it was at the
time and I pay income taxes on that.
Just like anything else,
I've invested in some bitcoin.
If I hold it for less than six months,
I'll declare a short term capital gains
more and more than a here I'll longterm
capital gains and pay the difference.
I mean,
that's basically how I
would work with euros.
That's how I'm going
to work with a bitcoin.
The key word you're saying
how you're going to,
that's what's interesting about this is
you actually haven't started doing that
yet because you've only been starting to
get paid fully in bitcoin over the last
few months.
So this is fairly
experimental even for you,
you're basically at the
cutting edge of this,
right.
So I mean there are people
who have already filed
Texas,
uh,
a few times and they've
used the same approach.
Um,
I'm going to be filing income taxes in
Bitcoin for the first time for 2013 but I
mean,
I'm discussing it with accountants and
they think it's pretty straight forward
when I think the IRS will
give us guidance before April.
And the reason I think they will is
because the IRS is interested in or in
making revenue and what better way to
make revenue from bitcoin than to simply
explain exactly how people should
pay their taxes on it so we can,
things are going to get
really weird if it takes off.
Yeah.
They're already weird and had
already took off you think.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
that's
of,
but I don't know anybody
who's using it all the time.
I mean,
you might say if you're,
you know,
you're on involved in these online groups,
but the actual percentage of people that
are using big coin and regular basis,
what is it,
one half of one half of 1% I mean is maybe
there are,
there's probably,
um,
you know,
several million.
Is it over 10 cents less
than 10 in this country?
No,
worldwide.
But most of it's in this country.
There's a,
there's a million people in this country
that are using bitcoin on a regular
basis.
Well,
that,
I don't know,
uh,
and it's,
and it's not easy to find out,
but what I do know is for it to
be taking off is what I'm saying.
So what I'm thinking about is,
in terms of taking off,
this has been around for five years.
It's been a very stable and secure
network that has preserved or increased in
value.
At the same time,
people have gradually
improve the technology.
Now we've got this whole raft to
startups that are doing innovation and
delivering better and
better products around it.
More and more merchants are
doing it and most importantly,
it's gone global.
It's now being used in dozens of countries
around the world and the network is
large and getting larger every day.
So all of those conditions reminds me
exactly of what the Internet was in 1992.
Again,
most people didn't hear about it until
94 95 and at that point you had people go
on the morning show and say,
you know,
is internet the email
or what's this at sign?
And then we're having that conversation.
But it had already been
growing quite rapidly.
I think that's where we are with bitcoin.
My mom is not going to do,
you know,
bitcoin on her own,
uh,
for another six or seven years.
Uh,
most people won't hear much about it
for the next two years are going to hear
about it occasionally.
But in the meantime it's been
building momentum and getting better.
And,
uh,
I think it's already arrived.
Certainly the invention behind it,
which has also spawned
many other currencies.
Um,
you can't uninvent invent that invention.
So in whatever form.
And if it's not this bit coin currency,
which I think is already
pretty damn strong.
Um,
you know,
that same invention can
be repeated and improved.
Just like you know,
the Internet's the first
early versions were really,
really clunky and gradually and improved
and keep in mind currency is just the
first application.
So if you were on the internet
and you only knew email,
you couldn't even imagine
what the web would be like,
let alone social media or mp3s
or digital music and video.
Internet still is a,
bitcoin is still like that.
We've got the bitcoin currency,
which is just like email and
it's the basic application.
Now companies are building the other
applications and it's getting really
exciting.
So I think we've got a bit
to go until we're mainstream,
but I think it's already
catching on now in other
countries it's the,
the government has been not so
sweet about the use of bitcoin.
And there's an article that came out
just a few hours ago from Russia,
the Russian central bank.
So the bitcoin users could face jail time.
They did.
Yeah,
it's up there.
It's actually was in Time magazine
a this is off Lariya Novo Ski.
Alright,
lovely.
I'll just
as you know that other countries
have done the same thing,
including China.
And I mean,
what if you use bitcoin and then,
you know,
two years from now they say it's illegal.
I mean,
are these,
well this is crazy.
This was released right
before we started the podcast.
A couple of hours before
we started this podcast,
they released the story.
So it's a fairly breaking news.
So I haven't seen the story.
What I can say,
first of all,
if it's saying that
it's the same in China,
they're wrong.
So that makes me wonder what
else they're wrong about.
But in China,
they banned central banks and
other banking institutions
from holding bitcoin on
their asset ledger.
They didn't ban people from trading.
In fact,
bitcoin is like 60% or more of
the trading happens in China.
They didn't ban people from using it.
It's perfectly legal to
use it there as well.
Um,
I think you might be,
it might be an exaggerated headlines,
but even if it isn't,
um,
you know,
if Russia bans bitcoin,
I think that probably ends up
hurting Russia more than bitcoin.
Yeah.
China's limited bitcoin
use for fruit citizens.
Apparently it's on a few different,
yeah.
China also limits a Internet
to use for its citizens.
So that doesn't devalue the Internet.
I mean,
that's the,
that's the point about this.
And keep in mind,
there's also a matter of due process
of law and there's also a matter of
different legal structures.
So for example,
in India,
the first reaction of
the of the regulator is,
was,
well,
if it's not specifically
licensed and permitted,
it's not legal.
That's their,
their legal system is
attitude is we say it's legal,
it's legal.
If we haven't said anything about it,
then it's legal for,
right.
You need the license.
So it's the inverse of US law.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
certainly,
uh,
here in the U s I'm not,
I'm certainly not worried
about it being pants,
hair,
because there is a lot of legal
precedent for private currencies in this
country.
And there's constitutional protections
and there's companies that can defend
themselves against that.
We,
you have a lot of people that listen
to this podcast from other countries.
It's one of the reasons why
I wanted to bring that up,
the Russia story,
but,
uh,
to point out that this is not a
universally accepted things as far as the
governments and the ambivalence
of American banks that
they've shown an American
politicians.
This is,
it may not be the case in other countries.
Was this Bank of Russia issues
warning on digital currencies?
Well,
you know,
Russia is incredibly suppressive place.
Uh,
we know that,
uh,
you know,
we know what's going on
with them and gay people.
I mean,
it's,
it's a,
a really,
uh,
it's appalling,
very strange,
backwards country in,
in terms of a lot of the things that
they think in a lot of the ways that they
behave as a nation.
And,
you know,
it's basically also run by one gangster.
It's a,
it's not a country of laws,
that's for sure.
Well,
I mean,
without a doubt,
Putin,
whether he's a great leader and not his,
uh,
his gangster,
you know,
he's just a super awesome when
at it he's running the country.
You used to be the president stepped down,
put a puppet government and probably
his and then became the president again.
I mean the whole thing is magical
and then rode around on a
horse bare chested splendour.
Yeah.
That was pretty crazy and weird.
Oh,
he does a lot of weird things.
Him and Obama were,
uh,
they were both conflicted.
They were in some area and they
were conflicted as far as like,
when they could use the gym,
take it.
They weren't allowed to use the gym
together for some fucking reason.
Like as if Putin and Obama can't
work out in the gym together.
Like,
do you know how fucking crazy that is?
dude,
I'll be on a stairmaster.
You hit the weights.
Is that cool?
No,
they can't be in the room together.
Like they're afraid that Putin might beat
him over the head with a fucking club
or something.
But so while Obama was
in the gym working out,
Putin jumped in the fucking
lake outside the gym.
So in,
in clear view of Obama and his,
uh,
you know,
it's fucking elastic bands and he's
doing his little aerobics stretches with
Putin swimming.
That's hilarious.
In a fucking lake.
Freezing,
freezing cold lake,
like a man,
like a bare chest at savage
and an old spice commercial,
a Russian old spice master.
Unbelievable.
They're just pissed
off about Alaska still.
Did you ever hear that old story that,
about how the,
they sold Alaska to us for,
I think it was like $12 million and
then we bought it from them like an or
whatever,
1,817 hundreds and then we found
so much gold in Alaska that,
that they would have,
you know,
tripled the amount that
we paid for Alaska.
Even just on gold.
Forget the oil and everything
else will ask is amazing.
They fucked up.
It's way better than Russia dummies.
They could have had a
vacation spot and we'll,
anchorage is the shit man.
I was one of my favorite
places I've ever visited.
It's amazing.
And the view that when you
drive into the mountains,
oh my God,
it's just magical up there.
It's incredible.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Russia is a weird spot,
man.
You know,
Russia has had a long,
hard history,
has been a lot of horrible things that
have happened to the Russian people,
both,
you know,
World War Two and before that there were,
they were occupied by the
Mongols for 200 years.
I mean,
it's just a rough country and
when it comes to their laws,
lemon,
they've got some really fucking shady
laws and real weird attitudes on things
too,
man.
You know,
they have a habit of shipping people
that don't agree with them off to Siberia
like that.
Um,
that one really wealthy oligarch fellow,
it was one of the most
richest men in Russia,
but crosswords,
Putin,
Putin just sent that motherfucker to jail,
kept him in jail for 10 years
and then finally released him,
have massive public outcry.
It's,
this guy was,
you know,
they trumped up charges against him.
Just locked them up in
a cage for a decade.
Yeah.
Well,
here's the,
here's the other perspective on this
switches in places like the u s if the,
if the government banned some things,
they go through a very
long arduous process.
They go through courts,
they have to prove their case.
They can just willingly do it
and it takes a long process.
And generally the people
kind of agree with it.
Now in a lot of places in the world when
something is banned by the government
that people go,
hmm,
maybe I should look into that.
So you know,
the fact that it's banned in Russia,
it doesn't necessarily mean
the bitcoin disappears.
It simply means that bitcoin is more
of an underground in that place.
And people have a lot less respect for
laws that are arbitrary and capricious.
So in countries where you have week
rule of law and you have rule of people
correspondingly,
the people don't pay
much attention to those.
Uh,
you know,
a lot of things are illegal in Russia,
including s you know,
buying and selling dollars
on the black market.
And you can do it on
every corner in Moscow.
Yeah.
Isn't essentially illegal to be gay.
I mean,
what are the,
what are the laws on gay people?
They're incredibly restrictive.
Right?
Okay.
Yeah,
I have,
I don't know what the,
I don't,
it's not illegal to be gay,
but I think it's more,
um,
uh,
there are still sodomy
laws and there are still,
um,
bans on public displays
and things like that.
It's,
it's really,
or even symbols.
They arrested someone on
the Sochi parade route with,
for holding a rainbow flag.
It was disgusting.
That's all
Marius the gays have
taken over the rainbow.
I love that.
We rainbows,
we were a kid.
It's like fucking leprechauns pot of gold,
you know,
beautiful sunshine after
the rain and now it's gay.
I'd the fuck did they do that?
You can get arrested for having
a fucking rainbow shirt on.
I would.
I'm just a fan of rainbows.
What if this rainbow shirt and you
got a Leprechaun at the end of it?
What did they say then?
If you have a rainbow shirt on
the Leprechaun and a pot of gold,
I'm sure you get that.
To argue that in court about three months
after you were arrested after spending
three months in a dungeon.
So yeah.
Well you have butt sex
while you were in there,
so it might be great.
Well that's the old Lenny Bruce joke.
You know,
there was like one of the
classic Lenny Bruce Jokes.
I don't understand why they would make
the laws against homosexuality dig.
They take a guy who's gay and they arrest
him and they put him in jail with a
bunch of men and when
I have sex with them.
Yep.
It was Lenny Bruce,
Lenny Bruce.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That was a classic.
That was one that people uh,
stolen.
They didn't even realize they stole it.
Yeah.
Because a lot of people
sort of recognize that.
It's like when I was,
uh,
an open mic night comedian,
I've lived in Boston and Boston is of
course south of New Hampshire and New
Hampshire had a license plate
that said live free or die.
And of course,
the,
the old classic story about license plates
is that they were made by prisoners.
So like 10 guys came up with
that joke independently.
The live free or die.
Well,
the problem with that is,
you know,
they're made by prisoners.
That's one of those things.
Yeah.
Bitcoin,
what,
where did we go?
We went off track,
went into the woods.
Is there any kind of insurance or it
company that's going to back up Bitcoin,
like an insurance company kind of like,
you know,
when a bank gets robbed,
US protected,
uh,
Ashley,
um,
as in many areas of kind
of emerging markets.
One of the first to move
in as Lloyd's of London,
which have historically been involved in,
in types of insurance that other companies
won't necessarily offer first and
introduce the new market.
So there was an organization
in the UK that will take,
uh,
where you can store bitcoin and then have
it in short by Lloyd's of London for a
specific fee and they'll
protect it from theft.
But here's the interesting thing.
Uh,
that's a,
that's a fairly limited approach to it.
But what you can do with,
with Bitcoin is you can take insurance
contracts and the guarantees of insurance
companies and embed them
into the transaction system.
So now you could have,
for example,
let's say when you go and buy something
on Ebay and you do a paypal transaction
and they give you the
ability to do escrow.
So if the product never
arrives at your doorstep,
you can get your money back.
Right now when you do that,
you have to use paypal escrow.
You don't really have a choice.
And when you do that with visa,
you have to use visa escrow.
Well,
on Bitcoin you can pick an escrow provider
and have them add their own key and
to the transaction and now they're going
to be your escrow and you chose them.
Um,
so you can pick from a market of escrow
companies and they can do it without
actually holding your money simply by
putting an extra key in the transaction
and neither authorizing it or not.
I see.
So it opens up all of these
possibilities for new forms of insurance,
new forms of escrow,
new forms of financial protections that
couldn't be done with traditional money.
The edge,
there was news just out that
a Jamaican bobsled team,
this was from bitcoin was it,
but it was a dodge coin
or whatever it's called,
raise $30,000 for this year's a Olympics.
Just the other day.
Yeah,
and I mean,
here's the other is story
that's not told very often,
which is the charity aspect.
In study after study,
after study looking both the charitable
organizations and user profiles,
um,
and questionnaires,
bitcoin users have said repeatedly that
the number one thing they do with their
bitcoin is donate or give them away.
Um,
charity is very active on the bitcoin
blocks blockchain on the bitcoin network.
Um,
just recently,
bitcoiners raised a ton of money for
the hurricane and the Philippines.
Um,
there's a number of charts
we'll organizations helping
the homeless in Florida.
Um,
there's other organizations
doing the same in San Francisco,
all based around bitcoin.
So there's this incredible
charitable giving spirit and it's on,
we're seeing that replicates
with other coins to,
um,
one of the other interesting ones is the
wikileaks recently announced that the
vast majority of their,
uh,
donations now come in cryptocurrencies.
Bitcoin,
unlike coin,
this is fascinating because
on certain payment networks,
you can't donate to,
to Wiki leaks,
right?
You can't donate to wikileaks was pay pal.
You can't donate to wikileaks with visa.
They ban you from doing that.
And that's how they've cut off
the funding of that organization.
Yet at the same time on some
of those payment networks,
you could donate to the Ku Klux Klan.
Now,
that doesn't represent my principals
and I have a big problem with that.
Well,
with bitcoins you can because you
simply can't donate to whoever you want.
You can just send Bitcoin to any address.
And as a result,
um,
you know,
wikileaks has seen rise in the donations
they receive,
uh,
through bitcoin.
But a lot of other organizations too,
it's,
there's a lot of charitable giving.
There's a lot of nonprofit
organizations using bit coin.
This is a fascinating time.
I mean,
how many other Bitcoin,
like alternatives are available.
And do you feel that those
are competition for big,
for Bitcoin or they just
as valid as bitcoin?
Is there room for a bunch
of cryptocurrencies?
What's the,
what's the attitude about that?
That's a great question because we,
uh,
generally speaking,
the term for alternative
currencies is altcoins.
Uh,
some of them are alternative,
some of them are,
uh,
more competitive with bitcoin.
All of them are based
on the same invention.
So what this shows is that the underlying
invention of how to do computational
agreement on the network that invention
has spawned all of these other
currencies.
Uh,
some of them are very innovative,
some of them are just fads and memes and
some of them are pump and dump schemes.
So there's a whole range.
One of the interesting things that this
has created is that in the past money
was trusted and had value because
not many people could create it.
And so we trust governments
to create money.
And money has value because
only governments can create
money now because anyone
can create money.
How you give it value
depends on other things,
which is actually a good lesson because
government money doesn't really have
that much value in a lot of places either.
It's just an illusion that
somehow that makes it valuable.
In the case of Bitcoin,
what makes bitcoin valuable is the
enormous amounts of investment.
Uh,
both in terms of resources,
in terms of the computing equipment
that people have bought in terms of the
invested companies that are in
it and the people who work in it.
Um,
other coins have slightly different
variations of the same theme.
Um,
and some of them are based on memes,
Internet memes.
But here's,
I see a future where a five year old at
school could use a web browser to build
a coin in an afternoon and
launch it among their friends.
So will there be more coins?
Yes,
tens of thousands of them.
And we'll,
those coins have value.
Probably not,
no more than baseball cards
or Pokemon or a Tamagotchi.
But within an environment
and with young people,
you're going to have,
you're going to have people who create
them for trading purposes and as memes
and,
and fats.
And so they'll have a
certain kind of value,
just not monetary value.
So you have to evaluate which coins have
monetary value based on what's running
behind them.
You know,
the bitcoin economy has an actual
economy behind it has merchants,
it has retail transactions,
it has a startup,
companies that are investing
in developing things with it.
Some of these other coins
have some of those things.
Some of them have none of those things.
But is there a risk of bitcoin being
like the myspace of cryptocurrencies when
you get off to
his big headstart and you're
way ahead of the game,
but there's holes in your game and right?
Facebook comes in and
steals all your people.
So one thing to realize is that money
is a lot more sticky than a social site.
Um,
and when people invest their skills and
expertise and companies into a certain
cryptocurrency,
that carries a lot of weight.
So bitcoin has already achieved a
very high level of network effect,
which means that the
more people are on it,
the more people that attracts,
the more people that are on it,
the more people that attracts.
But at the same time,
because it's building a
capital base that makes it,
that makes it very
difficult to unseat bitcoin.
Um,
I think what we'll end up seeing is,
uh,
one or two major currencies.
Bitcoin is probably
going to be the biggest,
um,
and then two or three or four or five
secondary currencies that do some kind of
niche thing that's useful for some group,
um,
that bitcoin can't do a won't do
because it sounds like for example,
a bitcoin has reverse inflation
deflation because there's a fixed supply.
So over time the value is
gradually going to increase,
right?
Um,
other people have created coins
where if you don't spend them,
you lose a bit,
which is like inflation.
So bitcoin is not going to be
able to copy that and take,
take that feature and say,
Hey,
that looks good,
let's do it too.
But for a lot of other things,
when an,
when an alternative coin
invents something new,
bitcoin can simply pick it up and run
with it to a big coin hasn't stopped
moving.
It was invented in 2008 and five years
of innovation have gone into it and the
level of innovation is accelerating.
So I think there's a lot of room for a
lot of coins in this space and not all of
them are going to have value,
but some of them will have value.
So are there any that stand down?
I know Doge Coin Dog,
he coin is one that keeps
getting brought up to me to,
to talk to you about on the Internet.
What about Kanye West's coin?
You know,
Kanye West has a coin,
so I think there are a few coins that
have interesting characteristics.
Um,
you know,
they implement new features,
they do things slightly better or slightly
different in some ways than bitcoin.
So what,
like what,
what do they do better?
Um,
well for example,
um,
one example is a light coin.
And what light coin does is
it has a different way of,
of having the agreement on the network,
which is,
which requires more memory
on your computer in less CPU.
So that makes it,
um,
more level at the same time.
Uh,
it does transactions that
are on a different pace.
So instead of every 10 minutes,
it does,
um,
you know,
fewer minutes for per block.
I think it's two and a half,
and then you have a larger
number of total coin.
So it's a few tweaks.
The idea is if bitcoin is gold,
light coin is silver.
Um,
but that's the general
competitive environments.
Now,
beyond that Doge coin is in
fact or dog coin or Doggy Coin,
whenever,
I'm not quite sure how it's pronounced is,
is an enhancement on the original,
um,
idea of light coin.
So it took that and then twisted it a bit.
And then you've got this whole
list of other coins that,
um,
some of them are interesting.
One discovers prime numbers,
which are useful in mathematics and the
other one uses a different peer to peer
system.
Um,
another one is more programmable.
One of the new coins that's come out now,
ethereum allows each transaction to be
a full code for programming language.
Um,
you know,
all of these may have interesting
characteristics and then,
you know,
Kanye West coin,
whatever,
and hey man,
dumped,
dismiss it.
No,
I mean it's great.
It comes to goal first.
First of all,
they got sued I think,
or they got cease and desists because
they had nothing to do with him.
Um,
but one of the interesting things is that
we don't know if one of these catches
on,
who knows why not a lot of things in life
started as a joke and then became huge
things that became
embedded in the culture.
So what,
let me ask you this.
What about these massive
fluctuations in value,
like day to day,
right?
In intense fluctuations?
Yes.
Very disconcerting to people that
are looking for a stable investment.
When you see what are the,
I mean,
several hundred percent,
right?
What is the worst day or the
best day as far as the variation?
So I think the best day was a was
maybe two and a half years ago,
which was a minus minus
40 minus 50% in a day.
That was a really big crash and it took
it to from above 32 below a dollar.
Um,
and then there was another crash around
a hundred and then there was another one
around to 66 and then there was
another one around the thousand.
And so we're now kind of in
a relatively stable band,
uh,
between 800 900,
somewhere there.
Okay.
Explain.
But here's the point over time is
these little hiccups get narrower and
narrower.
And here's why they occur.
If you look at the bitcoin,
the total market capitalization,
if you take all of the bitcoins that exist
times the value that they have on the
market today,
it's about a $10 billion market,
right?
$10 billion market might sound like a lot,
you know,
certainly if it was a tech stock,
it would be a nice size tech stock.
But as a currency is puny,
you know,
there are hundreds of countries that
have bigger monetary base for that
currency.
And this is an international currency.
It's small.
So what happens is this
is a shallow pool of,
of uh,
liquidity.
And when you have a shallow
pool of liquidity like this
with a few markets that
are not very efficient,
the end result is that
every time someone sneezes,
all of the liquidity sloshes around
and you get these fluctuations,
but as it gets bigger in size,
the waves get smaller,
right?
So it's not as volatile.
And if you look at it,
uh,
if you plotted on a graph
and you plot the volatility,
you'll see that every year it's getting
less and less and less and less and less
volatile.
Now,
if at some point it became large,
you know,
the reason currencies like the u s
dollar on it are not very volatile,
is because if you think of a $14
trillion economy is like a titanic,
it takes,
you know,
three miles to turn 10 degrees,
right?
So they're much more stable because they
have weight behind them and inertia.
And even if you want to change it,
you tweak something now and it changes
in six months because it takes time to
filter through the economy.
Meanwhile,
think of Bitcoin is like
a little Zodiac boat,
makes the titanic bouncing
up and down the waves,
very nimble,
both volatile over time as it gets
bigger than the waves get smaller by
comparison.
Okay,
what is the cause of these fluctuations
to a financial dunce like myself?
What,
what causes?
Like how can it be worth x amount
and then half that in the case.
So let me start by answering the implicit
question of how does it get its value?
Who sets the price?
Okay,
so it's a free market.
Uh,
and so if you go and try to buy bitcoin
online at the moment and you say,
I'm going to pay 800 for it,
and someone says yes,
and then during the day the vast volume
of people are buying and selling for
around a hundred $800.
Great.
That's the price of bitcoin.
It's whatever people are
paying to buy and sell bitcoin.
And so every time the order changes,
you know,
if suddenly you can't find anyone
to buy your bitcoin at 800,
you're going to discount it a bit and
discount until you find someone who's
going to buy it.
And then that's the new price.
So it will go down a bit.
But if you are finding people
easily to buy your bitcoin,
then you increase the price of it.
So it goes up a bit.
Just like the stock market.
Who sets the price of IBM?
No one,
it's whatever the last
deal was on IBM stock.
So,
uh,
how's that not make it vulnerable for
the same pump and dump issues that you're
experiencing with all these
other cryptocurrencies?
Well,
it,
it's,
it does make it vulnerable,
but the point is there's still
a fixed amount of bitcoin.
So right now that small
fixed amount of bitcoin with,
you know,
very big changes of media news piece
comes out and it's like Chinese people are
buying bitcoin woo.
And it goes,
you know,
really high.
Everybody gets really excited.
This is,
it is breaking through.
Then the next week,
Central Bank of China won't
let banks hold bitcoin down.
We go,
you know,
every piece of good news
pushes the price up.
Suddenly every piece of bad
news knocks it down suddenly,
but it seems like really manipulative
financial experts would be able to move it
left and right to their whim
in order to profit off of it.
Yeah,
on this probably a bit of that going on,
but I can tell you that there is a lot
more of that going on in every other
market.
So that's the interesting thing here.
We now know that Libor,
the interest rates in the Lenten than
bank system has been fixed for years and
that's the basis for most interest rates.
We know that the gold markets fixed,
we know that the stock markets,
they're doing front running on
high frequency transactions,
those are fixed.
Every single market out there is
currently rigged and so the people who are
playing within these markets with like
fiber optic connections to this main data
center,
you know,
and they're three feet closer than the
other server and can get that transaction
in four nanosecond sooner.
Our front running
transactions are benefiting,
are profiting from that distance
and these markets are rigged.
You know,
you go in with you a little brokerage
accounts and you trade some IBM and you
think you're playing the game,
right?
You're the dunce in the room cause you
don't know who the dunce and the room is.
What you're talking about with automated
transfers like that where you're
dealing with Nano sock,
high frequency trading as it's
called their algorithmic trading.
Unbelievably fascinating stuff.
Yes.
I mean literally they have racks trying
to get closer to the rack where the
transactions are happening
until data centers had to say,
no matter where you are in the room,
you're getting 300 feet of fiber and if
it's coiled at the bottom of your rack
or if it's stretched out,
since you're still going to have to go
soon so that everybody gets the same
deal.
But right now,
for example,
uh,
all of the banks are playing this game.
How can fast can you do a transaction?
So what I'm saying is yes,
there is manipulation
in the bitcoin market,
but the manipulation is on the stock,
on the exchange rates,
is that that happens
on a day to day basis,
but it's not on the supply of money.
Whereas in the real economy,
the stock market,
the New York stock has changed.
Not only is the market rigged,
and not only is the
market been manipulated,
but the currency itself is
rigged and being manipulated.
The Fed is printing money
and handing it to the banks.
So the lesser of two evils,
it's definitely the
lesser of the two evils.
And also the larger it gets,
the harder it is for
outsiders to manipulated,
right?
Because they don't control the
levers of power of the currency.
There are no leavers,
and that's the beauty of it.
So you create a system that doesn't
have leavers to control the currency.
So all they can control is
the price and manipulated.
But that's a dangerous game to play
long term because if the market turns
against you,
you lose a lot of money too.
So it's currently worth how much is
a bitcoin worth in American dollars?
Um,
so one place to look up is bitcoin
average.com and that shows you the average
across dozens of exchanges
all around the world.
At the moment it's a 700,
hang on one bitcoin is 784 US
dollars on average at the moment.
And that's fairly stable cause you
were talking about it at 800 before.
So it's pretty close for the last
month it's been in that band.
Um,
we have seen some wild swings,
but it seems to be stabilized
around that level now,
which by the way is three times the
level it had stabilized before the big
bounce and how much bitcoin is actually
available out there in the world.
So I'd have to look that up.
I would say about 11 million
or so have been created so far.
And there's a constant creation
of these every 10 minutes,
25 and this constant creation will
eventually not just level off,
but one day stop.
Yes.
Now what happens then?
Well,
the thing is it,
it's,
it starts operating more
like a precious metal,
which is that,
you know,
once supply of a precious
metal gets restricted,
it increases in value.
But the one difference
is that a precious metal,
you can only shave so thin,
you can't cut it into smaller units and
it's difficult to transport and all of
that.
Where's Bitcoin?
You can divide it into
100 million sub units.
So basically instead of the money in your
pocket losing value over time because
the central government is diluting it,
it's getting concentrated because
more people want to use it,
then there's not enough around.
So it gains value in your pocket
and that's a deflationary currency.
Uh,
it creates some interesting
savings opportunities.
Where do you see this going?
How,
how,
where do you,
what do you see like the future
and a hundred years from now,
what do you,
what do you think bitcoin's place
in the world is going to be?
I think I can make certain
predictions for sure.
And I can make other predictions
with absolute 90% margin,
which means I'm pulling it out of my ass.
So let me tell you one
I can make for sure.
Cryptocurrencies will be part
of our financial future period.
Doesn't matter what form they take.
This invention has been invented.
It will change finance,
it will change banking.
Uh,
and it might not be bitcoin.
I think it will,
but it might not be bitcoin,
but it will still be a cryptocurrency.
The idea of having a mathematical currency
based on a distributed peer to peer
network happened.
The invention happens.
You can't stop people from
coming up with variations on it.
You can't easily shut it
down if you shot down 100,
others are going to pop up in its place.
Now at the same time,
I think bitcoin has a very good chance
of being the one that was good enough.
The grew fast enough and gained enough
traction that it will actually have,
uh,
as a store of value value
for a very long time.
Now,
didn't someone sell a house
and Canada through Bitcoin?
We've seen transactions as big
as $150 million by the way.
Guess what the fee was?
What?
Zero whoa.
Hundred and 50 million transferred
in seconds for zero fee.
Whoa.
Who?
Who got $150 million in Bitcoin?
Justin Bieber.
That crazy.
Fuck who's who did that?
Were they drunk?
We have no idea.
Oh,
they must have been drunk as well.
No,
no.
I mean,
you see,
look at the text messages.
You mean when you were drunk and
then look at your bitcoin folder.
I did what you think you would know if
somebody spent that much money using
bitcoin because they would,
you know,
as a bitcoin user would probably scream,
I just spend on one point $5 million.
That's why it's so weird for me to think
that like the the guy that created it,
no one knows is what he looks like.
Some guys,
he spent one point $5 million
but no one knows who this guy.
It just seems so weirdly.
Here's the thing,
you don't know what's happening
in the banking system today.
People are sending
billions of dollars around,
but for bitcoin users,
they're all,
it's almost like buying a cell
phone in your advertising.
Like this is the best cell phone ever.
I love it.
You know that your cell phone sucks cause
they are almost the most vocal about
using bit coin that you would think
somebody going to spend 1.5 would,
would immediately go to online.
What do you mean?
Hold on,
I'll tell the world I have all this money.
That's a dangerous thing to say.
Why would you,
why would you think that that's what
they would do and if they didn't do that
they wouldn't,
it wouldn't be real.
No I didn't say it's not real.
It just says it seems so suspicious
that you know that there's so many.
See that my biggest
problem cause I've been,
people have been trying to get me to a
bitcoin for the longest time is things
like this where it's,
it just seems there's so
much mystery to it like that.
Especially if you follow
the conspiracies of the,
the guy that created it.
And if,
and you know you hear reports
like somebody just spent,
well you know all these millions
of dollars using bit coin.
Yes.
I already said,
he said someone bought
one point $5 million,
transferred to $5 million transaction.
There was a transaction from
one address to another address,
$450 million in a single transaction
who can keep in mind minute 150 million.
Yes.
And these happen every second.
Not Not that big,
but transactions happen all the time.
And so as you,
if you were watching the
stream and transaction,
you're like,
you know,
$10 a thousand dollars
$500 $10,000 150 million.
And you're like,
what?
Well,
and you can see that transaction
because it's on the public ledger.
And it did happen and it
has been firefight and the
transaction went through and
they paid zero fee.
So this hundred and $50 million
transaction was between two people.
It was between two addresses.
So it might've been person moving in
from one of their own accounts to one of
their own accounts or,
or given it someone else.
But it's still 150 million
American dollars worth of.
It was about (406) 140-5000 bitcoin
and bitcoin is worth $800 each.
Yeah.
So at the time it was almost a thousand.
So yeah,
it's about 150 million.
Wow.
Which in the big scheme of things,
by the way,
in the global monetary system is peanuts,
but it's not user though.
If it's either an individual
you or if it's an a,
is it a corporation?
The corporation might be the government.
Yep.
When we seize the Silk Road,
the government,
meaning we,
uh,
Hu
government,
the government keeps,
keep kept that right there.
They're actually,
um,
I don't think they want to keep it
for too long and I'm not sure they,
they are allowed by law
to keep it for too long.
So what they've announced they're going
to do is they're going to sell it.
They're going to sell Silk Road.
No,
they're going to sell the bitcoins.
They seized
and they're going to sell them on the,
on some kind of market or auction,
which is,
which is great because it's going
to create some discount treating.
That's funny because bitcoin was a key
player in that whole silk road scandal.
And for folks who don't
know what Silk Road was,
it was a website that allowed you to buy
a lot of illegal things online and some
of it was purchased through
bitcoin and those things were,
is illegal as drugs or as guns or
there was a lot of different things,
right?
Yeah.
Well it's the,
it's was mostly drugs and the just today,
53 minutes ago or whatever,
I don't know the guy
that,
those two people got
arrested for that from the,
the,
they had a company that was a,
a laundering money using bitcoins,
allegedly,
allegedly.
Definitely someone who sold
bitcoin to users who bought drugs.
Right,
exactly.
Money Laundering for drug.
Let's be clear,
the allocation,
I read the indictment and on the plane,
and I'm not a lawyer,
but what it,
what it said is that allegedly,
uh,
these people sold bitcoin to someone
who then resold it on the Silk Road to
other users,
some of whom he used it to buy drugs.
So how could somebody be responsible for,
that's up.
That's like,
that's a three hop allegation.
And in my mind,
if that's the standard,
then at least half of Wall
Street should be in cuffs.
Right now the thing it's allegedly,
so let's keep that in there.
I mean,
yeah,
many we've used many allegedly is,
it's very important.
Well this is a,
there's a lot of exaggerated,
exaggerated claims and statements
in prosecution indictments.
When you're a career prosecutor and you
write up the indictments and decide to
take it to the grand jury,
you're not going to just write
the littlest thing you do.
You're going to make it look like,
Eh,
you know,
every person who arrest is the worst
person in the world and has massive crimes
going on,
which means that reading fats and
seeing how much of a weak case it is,
you know,
allegedly sold to someone who allegedly
sold to users who allegedly both drugs.
Um,
I dunno,
it seems insane.
It's almost like your employee,
uh,
buys drugs with money that you paid him
so you are in trouble for him buying
drugs.
I'm not a lawyer.
I'm not going to figure out
what sort of connection,
the same direct sort of connection
and let's see them try and prove it.
I mean that's the best,
the justice system.
You have to,
you have to prove it.
Yeah.
But it's so scary that someone's
freedom is on the line for something as
ambiguous as that.
Especially when you're dealing with
someone's selling bitcoin to someone who
used then use that bitcoin to buy
drugs once it's out of your hands.
Scary as he got a 24 year
olds sitting in jail for this.
And you've got the 55 year old CEO of
HSBC who didn't even resign after being
fined hundreds of millions of
dollars for laundering billions.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Government don't make us use the internet
to run everything that's gonna happen,
right?
Yeah.
I mean this is actually probably owned
by the government and there you're going
to use it and voting in the
future and like you said,
it's probably going to be,
it doesn't matter if it's
owned by the government.
Look,
listen,
the government,
the government invented the,
the basic protocols behind the internets
and then engineers and geeks took it
and turned it into a global network.
And even if the governments had
invented the math behind bitcoin,
we know how it works.
It's math and we're using it to do
things that the government doesn't
necessarily control that well.
So if they did invent it,
that was a bad idea.
Often some people,
someone says it was the internet,
the underlying technology,
there's nothing mysterious about it.
Can read the source code.
You can see how it works,
you can understand how it works and
you're not trusting anyone specific.
You're just trusting that you
understand how it works and it's math.
I mean,
that's the beauty of it and that's why
it people are adopting it so easily is
because there's no one behind the curtain.
Yeah.
It's,
it's also,
it's sexy.
You know,
it's the new kid on the block.
It's the new exciting thing.
It's the,
the,
as you said,
the Internet of money.
Yeah.
And people want to be the first adopters.
They want to get on it first.
Okay.
That flux happening in this economy.
I mean really,
let's think about it.
What else is happening in this economy
now other than the military under,
other than I'm more derivatives piled
on the Huppah more derivatives by the
banks.
Pretty much everything
else is at a standstill.
Set Marijuana.
The money from marijuana.
Yeah.
Well that's the one thing in this economy
that's exploded in the places where
it's been introduced and allowed to,
to uh,
operate in the free market.
And ironically,
those,
the,
the situation there was that they weren't
letting those people who are selling
the marijuana put their money in banks.
The government has since amended that
and said that they're going to now start
allowing these people who run
these medical marijuana stores to,
uh,
put their money in banks,
which is a huge victory.
And I think,
you know,
ultimately it's unconscionable.
Do anything else because you're,
you're allowing a,
an environment where crime,
violent crime is most likely going to
take place because you are making people
targets.
If you're not allowing them to bank,
you're,
you're making sure they have massive
amounts of cash on them on a regular basis
and they're going to get targeted.
It's just a matter of time.
You're,
you're creating,
you're going to create
victims of a violent crime.
So I'm glad they decided to not do that.
But that's a perfect example of the
kind of fuckery that's involved in our
government that you could have these
people that did pass a law allowing
something to be legal.
And yet still those people are kept from
in prohibited from putting that money
in banks.
It's nuts.
It's madness.
I mean,
the broader scheme of
this is understanding that
there's ways to deal this
through law,
including the People's
propositions in these states.
And then there's a lot
of these extra legal,
uh,
you know,
shenanigans that happen where suddenly
someone gets audited for a dozen years in
a row,
right?
Yeah.
And Yeah,
J J Edgar Hoover had people
audited every year of their life,
um,
because he didn't like them.
And some of those practices,
Keno continue to this day.
Now I prove least like to
see the rules followed.
I mean that's the whole
point of this country is,
and it's a rule of law
equally apply to all.
At least if we know what the rules are,
you can follow them or choose not
to and then face the consequences.
But if you don't even know what the rules
are because people may come up as they
go along,
that's not a good place to live.
Yeah.
If a a business,
a private business acted the way the IRS
did as far as like handing out audits
to people that were political opponents,
handing out audits to
people that were personal,
opponents of people that in power,
if a private company acted out that way,
they would be guilty of all
sorts of fucking violations.
It probably be somebody in jail.
I mean it would be a really
big issue if you found out,
but they've been auditing people just
to fuck with him for the longest time.
It's,
it's pretty gross and scary thing.
Well,
the good news is there now to auditing
bitcoiners and so far we have a nice
relationship,
uh,
with the IRS and they're looking
for ways to help us pay our taxes.
And I'm looking forward to that time.
I'm looking forward to filing my taxes,
uh,
and paying them this year.
I'm fascinated.
I mean,
I pay them every year paying,
paying Texas specifically for the
bitcoin earnings I've had this year.
I'm fascinated,
I'm fascinated to see that
this yuck Amo Nakamoto guys.
How do you say his name?
Satoshi Nakamoto.
So Toshi Yakamoto,
have you met this cat?
No one's been solution that
Comodo I think got real.
That's what I'm saying.
Well,
I mean there's,
there was a possibility
no one's mad at him.
There was a possibility that,
well,
here's what we know.
We know what he wrote and
based on what he wrote,
we know his name by changing it to numbers
and doing it backwards and googling
stuff.
And it was Savannah.
If you type in his name
backwards into Google,
it leads you to this whole real long a
discussion on some board about bitcoins.
And I'm like stealing them.
And stuff like that.
It's a really weird,
okay,
I stopped.
Just continue.
Sorry about him.
No,
no,
no.
The,
the,
the thing about Satoshi Nakamoto is we,
he's written a scientific paper,
right?
And before that paper,
and after that paper,
he participated in the community for two
and a half years having conversations
about how to do this.
So what we know is he's a scientist.
He's a scientist,
heavily involved in cartography and
economics and in digital currencies,
which is a space that's been
thriving for 20 years now.
And he,
she,
they found a way to solve a specific,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
He,
she,
they,
so does she Nakamoto
might not be a person.
Satoshi Nakamoto might be a woman.
Satoshi Nakamoto might be a group of two
or three people collaborating under a
pseudonym to create a scientific solution.
It doesn't matter.
They invented science.
Oh,
for sure.
It doesn't matter,
but aren't you fascinating?
Oh,
I'm totally fascinated.
But here's the lesson we've learned.
Prometheus's stole fire from the Gods
and gave it to the people and they tied
him to a fucking rock and had an
eagle eat his liver every day.
So Tosha Nakamoto gave money to the people
and he disappeared because he's smart
enough or she's smart enough
not to get tied to a rock.
That's the bottom line.
I don't look into it because I think
only bad things can come out of,
uh,
outing Nakamoto.
I see what you're saying.
They get smeared immediately.
Right.
And there's nothing good that will come
out of it because at the end of the day,
since they control nothing,
and since what they invented
is a mathematical solution,
it doesn't matter.
So you believe that potentially
this group of people or individual person,
whatever it was,
whichever scenario,
whichever sacks that they,
they
thought about it in advance and Oh,
they said they spent several
years working on the,
I mean there active and not just the,
the code.
I'm talking about the repercussions of
their actions and they decided to be
anonymous in their delivery of this.
Well,
I think throughout the 90s a lot of
the people involved in digital currency
environment because some of
them were working in oppressive,
highly oppressive environments.
And you know,
people may be working from Burma or
from China or from who knows where.
And so it's not a good thing to be
doing these with your own name attached.
So they made a lot of people in this space
where involved anonymously to protect
their own safety.
I was at working in digital currencies,
basically doing science
work in cryptography ends,
mathematics and distributed systems.
That's a very sexy part of the story.
You can't leave that out
anymore when you tell the story.
You got to tell people that nobody
knows if Satoshi Nakamoto is even real.
That's kind of cool.
Yeah,
it is kind of cool.
But,
uh,
you know,
we do know some things about Satoshi,
for example,
he puts two spaces after every period,
or she or she or they were,
or is that guy?
That's the Toshi,
Toshi.
A lot of people have tried to
gas and there's a lot of uh,
a lot of digital currency,
uh,
scientists and cartographers,
well known cryptographers who participated
in the creation of many of the
aspects of bitcoin and people
are fingered them and said,
you know,
maybe that's the toll.
She may be,
that's the Toshi,
maybe they're also Toshi.
I am Sitoshi so this is sort of
almost like a jack the ripper sort of
investigation only.
He didn't kill anyone.
He gave science to the people.
Well,
I mean in terms of,
there's so many different theories of
who you ever watched a documentary on it
solve Jack The ripper is murder,
you know,
they always find out that
it's a totally different gods.
It's like a great story.
I mean,
you know,
this person invented a completely
new science people or people and,
and then disappeared for
their own safety and yeah,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah,
it is fast and it's going to be ripe
for conspiracy theories of all kinds to
jump out of that.
And you know,
I tried to focus primarily
on the technology because I,
it stands alone.
That's the key.
It doesn't need any of this.
There is a culture,
there's a history,
there's all of that.
Then it's fascinating,
but the technology just works and it's
simple math and people can read it,
understand how it works,
and then use it.
And that's the beauty of it because
it doesn't depend on anyone.
You don't have to trust the Toshi.
You don't have to trust the bank and you
don't have to trust that someone's not
going to mess it up because
you can see how it works.
That's such a subject as ripe
for conspiracy theorists.
Boy,
they're going to jump all over that one.
Then you got a big foot.
They're going to chem trail
the fuck out of that one.
Okay,
well,
yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's already happening.
The tower seven,
this shit out.
How can we make a connection
with bitcoin entire seven?
There has to be something.
It's all fun.
Tower seven.
Hell,
the original computer
that created Bitcoin,
it wasn't done at 2008 it
was done in 2001 the NSA,
the CIA,
and the DEA.
I've met that guy,
Alex Jones.
Oh,
was that complex?
Jones?
I was just guessing.
I've met several guys like that.
Yeah,
well there's a lot of those guys.
Boy,
there's some fucking
ferocious conspiracy theorists out there.
Um,
I'm,
I'm fascinated by these things.
I'm fascinating by these new avenues
that our culture starts going down and
these incredible avenues and branches of
possibility off of these new new paths.
It's just a really amazing,
amazing time in so many ways.
And this highlights just this constant
repeating subject that comes up with me
and my friends is that W it's,
the Internet has changed everything,
everything.
And we've pretended that
it's only been a little bit,
oh,
so you get email now.
What's the big deal?
It's,
it's monstrous.
Yeah.
It's changed.
It's changed my life.
A 100% change the way I think 100% changed
my connection with just random human
beings.
I,
I interact with thousands of random
human beings online on a daily basis.
And 99.9999% of those
interactions are positive.
Yes,
exactly.
That's the most beautiful aspect about it.
Like
bitcoin is just an expression of that.
It's a child of the Internet.
You know,
when people say,
you know,
the intranet now is so cooperative and
restrictive that you can't do anything.
Well I can tell you you can
because bitcoin came right
out of that and works on
that perfectly today.
So you know,
the bit bitcoin is one more thing that
happens because of the Internet and now
it's turning around.
And here's the interesting thing.
It allows you to do
very small transactions,
micro nano transactions.
So for example,
if you want to monetize your podcast
and you accepted bitcoin and people sent
you a 10th of a penny or a penny or a
dollar and you added up over hundreds of
thousands of users because it doesn't
cost much to send because it's an easy
transaction.
People will make transactions
smaller and smaller and smaller.
So suddenly bitcoin can fund all of the
independent content providers and all of
the independent infrastructure providers
on the intranet and transformed the
Internet again from the inside out.
Wow.
Like imagine all of these media companies
that have gotten so horribly disrupted
because there's basically
two media models.
If you make content on the Internet,
you either sell advertising.
So you're stuffing junk into the
eyeballs of your customers or your ears.
And the bigger the company,
the more junk that comes out of it,
right?
Or you're selling your customer
if the product is free,
your the product,
right?
Right.
Your personal information
is what generates the value.
So if you're on a social
media site that's free,
you're the product.
And so they're selling your
information in order to make money.
So it's either advertising
or selling your information.
Well now there's this third way,
which is you can do transactions small
enough to have value when accumulated in
large numbers.
The you could independently and
directly funds content providers and
infrastructure on the Internet
and break the hold of these,
you know,
um,
systems of concentration that advertising
and social media have become privacy,
selling privacy and,
and selling advertising,
which require concentration.
They require enormous concentration.
What do you think if we set up a
dedicated Joe Rogan experience?
Bitcoin server right here
where we do not server,
but computer could have advocated to
just crunching just out of respect.
Yeah.
I just have one running here
in the background all the time.
Yeah,
we joke.
Can we go to jail for that?
Is that possible?
No,
of course not.
In fact yet,
you know,
at the end of the show,
uh,
I'd like to help set you
up with a wallet on your,
on your smart phone and
I'll send you some bitcoin.
Sure,
sure.
Um,
the other question I
wanted to ask you about,
we,
we spoke about earlier was net neutrality.
Now,
um,
that that's a huge issue for anyone who
loves the way the Internet works and the
way the internet does not judge and the
Internet is freely available to anyone
who poe ports into it
at virtually whatever,
you know,
you pay for your connection,
your,
you're going to,
you know,
whatever your download speed is.
But there's no,
there's no regulation as far as like it
being easier for Walmart to get online
or they have more of a percentage of the
pipe or what are we concerned about net
neutrality being somehow or another
compromise by nefarious sources?
Well,
I mean that's your travels.
He suffered a massive setback in the
courts just a couple of weeks ago with a
decision that allowed to
Verizon communications,
so not be subject to the FCC rule,
imposing net neutrality,
and that sent shockwaves through the
industry because the average down what?
What was the,
the Internet lost.
What?
What was the case?
The case was the FCC made a rule that
said that carriers must support net
neutrality and for ice and suit and had
it overturned as unconstitutional or
outside the mandate to the
FCC to be more accurate.
What did Verizon specifically want?
Well,
we don't know that they say they
want to make the internet better,
but they just got the rule that says that
they have to treat all traffic equally
taken out.
And most people don't realize that the
reason the internet allows things like
Netflix to happen is because they
didn't have to ask anyone's permission.
Now imagine if when Netflix started it
had to ask Comcast to run as traffic and
pay for premium.
Well,
they wouldn't do that
because it's a competitor.
So of course they'd crowd the out
of the market with exorbitant fees.
Net neutrality means that everybody has
a fair shake to be heard and it's up to
the end user to decide who
they want to listen to.
All of the traffic will reach you if you
wanted as the listener or as a viewer.
Now,
Ken,
they somehow or another limit where the
traffic goes to like what we're seeing
in other countries where they
have restrictive internet laws.
Is that a potential,
I think for product to this case,
I think the biggest threat right now
it comes to companies like Netflix or
things like I'm streaming
radio and audio systems,
a Spotify,
Pandora,
etc. Whereby a service providers who
have their own TV streams or their own
music streams that are competing are
going to make their experience great.
And Netflix experience somewhat suckier,
so they'll limit the bandwidth
of Netflix applications.
They'll choke them.
Right?
Right now.
I mean they already do in some cases,
but how they do that?
Well,
I mean they all kinds of shenanigans,
but I mean the bay,
the basic deal is that this FCC rule was
trying to establish a legal framework
on the,
which they'd be obliged to give equal
access to all contents as long as the
viewer chose,
that's what they want to see.
Or they wanted to connect
to all of the Internet.
They would connect to that with the
same bandwidth that they've bought.
A,
you buy bandwidth and you use it for
whatever you want and you don't get better
bandwidth if you use their shows.
The Netflix,
well,
once they tried to put that rule in place,
you know,
um,
the lawsuit started and now we have a
very bad decision that could really,
really hamper innovation.
A lot of the things that we see today on
the Internet would not have happened if
net neutrality weren't
observed and the Verizon,
for many people who don't realize this,
Verizon offers home Internet
connection as well as four g and,
and TV most importantly,
right.
And pay per view and video on demand,
which means that they're directly
competing against other content providers.
Verizon now has a fiber
optic system that's,
you know,
incredibly fast and connects to you direct
download movies and television shows.
There's a lot going on
right now as far as um,
uh,
as far as internet related content,
things like Netflix and things like,
I mean Hulu and Hulu plus and there's
these places are now starting to create
their own programming as well.
Right.
Getting really fascinating cause they're
not just competing with Verizon now.
They're competing with NBC
and CBS and what have you.
And if you like that net neutrality is
why it happens and therefore we should be
defending that you trial.
So what people should do is probably
boycott companies that don't support net
neutrality.
Sure.
I'm a huge supporter of the eff
electronic frontier foundation that's been
fighting for privacy and liberty.
And then you travel to on the
Internet since the early nineties,
and they've won several substantial
cases both against organizations like the
NSA,
but also against a service providers
that tried to abuse their position to
prioritize traffic.
And they've promoted the idea of an open,
independent,
transparent and fair Internet for all,
uh,
with equal access for everyone.
I mean,
that's the thing that's made
the Internet magic and they've
been@theforefrontofdoingthattoeff.org
I'm a huge supporter.
That's interesting.
Well,
we'll look into that and maybe we'll
fucking put an eff sticker on our website
or something like that.
And you can put it on your webcam too.
They're the same ones who
sell those little things.
Yeah,
well those guys are on the ball.
that's,
that's something to
really be concerned with.
It really is the idea that they
could limit your experience,
whether it's Netflix or whatever.
Downloadable charter does it to Jamie.
I,
they won't let them go
to pirate bay anymore.
And I've heard that before.
Allegedly,
allegedly,
allegedly he doesn't go to pirate bay.
Fuck,
well,
I need to download a legal lego league,
legal music,
legal like nine inch nails.
So if you're in an area where
they have a lockdown on,
on Internet providers,
you know,
where some people like
can only get Verizon,
they're in an area that only gets rise
and like 18 t doesn't reach their time
Warner's and reach there.
That sucks.
That's,
that's so disturbing.
And it's so contrary to the,
the trends that we would
like to see as far as,
here's one good idea.
One could thought that comes out of this.
A lot of the problem right now is that
you pay for both of your infrastructure
and your content in a single payment.
Your Isp,
well with bitcoin you could
pay the recipients of the
content provider directly
in tiny,
tiny,
tiny payments.
So you really are the bitcoin genius,
your bitcoin Jesus.
Because you,
um,
he is because he's buying bitcoin
as a solution for everything.
Well,
I mean,
it's powerful stuff fixed that
and bitcoin can fix the Internet.
Bitcoin can fix Verizon.
It's almost an I'm not,
it's just,
you know,
it's almost like evangelists
stick like it almost like a,
like pyramids.
Like when you go to a pyramid type
thing where they're sounding like,
no you're not you.
Is there anything you don't like about it?
Like what's the number one
thing that you're like,
I hope something changes with this.
Is there anything,
yeah,
sure.
I mean it's got a,
it's got some scalability
issues that are being solved.
It's a,
it's software so we have to be
very careful with the upgrades.
Um,
but you know,
I mean compared to the
existing form of money we have,
I honestly think it's
better money and it's,
and it's a great technology.
I've spent 20 years doing
security and distributed systems.
That's my area of expertise
as a professional.
So what I love about this is that I can
see the elegance of the technology and I
understand its implications.
The last time I felt like this was 1992
and it was because I saw the internet
and I saw the elegance of its and I was
out telling as many people as I could,
you know,
this is really going to change
things in ways you don't even expect.
And I can't even explain to
you yet because it's going
to unfold in ways no one
anticipates.
Because what it does is it
democratizes information.
So yes,
I'm excited about something
that democratizes money,
but it's because I understand
the underlying technology.
Uh,
you know,
I don't profit from talking about this.
Uh,
I'm able to build a career on it.
Sure.
And I love doing it,
but really at the,
at the heart of it,
I'm a geek.
I love the technology and that
passion just comes through.
It's obvious.
It's obvious that you love it.
You light up and you,
you when the word bitcoin
comes out of your mouth,
it comes out just covered in love juice.
You love it.
It's obvious and it's
interesting and it's,
it's,
um,
you're in a very unique position because
you're really at the edge of it and
you're,
you're sort of at the front of this
ever increasing in mass ship and a,
you're watching a game momentum.
It's got to be pretty exciting.
It's exciting.
It's,
it was also terrifying
for quite a while.
I mean,
I've been in this full time for almost
two years and I can tell you that that
was a not a very profitable,
a job for living before that.
Um,
I've been an independent freelancer.
I've been starting businesses.
I'm an entrepreneur,
so I was an independent
freelancer and linking them.
What,
what is your,
your,
your background,
your education and background?
I'm a computer scientist with a
specialization in distributed systems.
Uh,
I've been working in security for just
over 18 years in information security
systems.
So I worked as a consultant.
I worked as an advisor.
I worked as a chief information
officer for companies.
I built research companies.
I built,
uh,
companies that built,
Internet systems and I
followed the Internet.
I'm not one of the
pioneers of the Internet.
I was the 16 year old kid looking over
their shoulder as they were doing these
things,
you know,
so I was buried in it when
I was young and you know,
so I've,
uh,
I've worked as a,
as an independent professional
in this space for many years.
And then two years ago I
first discovered bitcoin.
Then it hit me again a second time.
I read this little sheet of paper and I
decided this is the job I'm going to do
and right now if there is no job,
so I'm not gonna make any money at it,
but I'm going to do this job
until it actually becomes a job.
And I did that for two years and I almost
went bankrupt because there wasn't a
job there at the beginning.
And now it's a job and it's very exciting.
So this is a conscious decision on your,
your part back when it
wasn't even profitable?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Massive chance and stepped
out on the edge of the dock.
Yes.
I invested in several companies.
I drained my retirement accounts,
I drained my savings,
paying my bills until I could
generate income doing this.
Wow.
And I,
I've,
I mean this is not prudent investment.
This is not prudent behavior financially.
But as a,
as a technologist,
as a person who's worked
in distributed systems and,
and security and computer systems,
I could see that this was an exciting
technology and I want to build a career in
it.
So what I've been doing is swapping
money for skills and experience and the
opportunity to be on the ground floor.
I was too young when the Internet started
to to be influential in that space and
I see this opportunity as a
second opportunity to do that.
Now.
How did you know that
Bitcoin was the solution?
What made you so confident that you
invested as exorbitant amount of time in,
in,
in bitcoin and you know back two years
ago that the future could not have looked
nearly as bright as it looks now?
So the key,
the key here was that I was in distributed
systems and security and then the
first time I thought I heard about it,
I thought nerd money and then
the s like everybody does,
right?
That's where Brian is,
that possible can't possibly work.
Then I went back and I read this a Toshi
paper and I grasped the science and it
was confusing that I read it again and
I really grasped the science and then
suddenly it hit me.
Oh my God,
this isn't a currency.
It's a consensus network.
This is the grail of distributed systems.
Of the last 15 years,
you can do so much more than currency.
And once that light bulb went off,
all I could see was the possibilities.
Oh well now that we have this technology,
we can do this and this and this and the
currency will do these things for us.
And you know,
all of these possibilities
unfolded in my head.
And it was,
it was a really dizzy experience,
but I understood the fundamental building
blocks looked so much like the early
Internet and I knew what
structures like that do.
They create a network effect.
They create this attractive force where
it gets more useful the more people who
use it.
Now,
work effect was coined first by Bob mad
calf in 1984 he said the value of the
network increases exponentially
with the addition of each node.
Because when you join a network,
you don't just getting that value,
but by increasing the size of the network
to make it more valuable for everyone
else because they have one
more person to connect to.
Right.
And if you keep doing that,
it achieves a scale where
it starts multiplying.
That's how the Internet grew and when
you have this magic combination of money
for the people that can be
sent directly between people,
the forms,
a network,
those three things came together.
In my head I'm like,
this is,
this is big and nobody knows it yet.
And when you see something that
big and nobody knows it yet,
you want to tell everyone and you want
to dedicate a large part of your time to
doing this because it's
incredibly exciting.
Now,
how did you initially jump in?
I mean,
how do you jump in in
the infant stages of,
of Bitcoin,
what it,
what's the steps that you
took to become a part of this?
Well,
I spent months and months and months
reading everything that I could,
the scientific papers and discussions
that Satoshi Nakamoto had with the other
developers as he developed it.
I started reading the code,
I started writing code,
I started building businesses around it.
I started talking to people.
I started meeting up with other bitcoin
enthusiasts and then as soon as I could,
I started buying bitcoin and you know,
and basically have been doing that since.
And what does your average day now
consist of going on podcasts and telling
people how awesome bid coin is?
How often does that come up?
So I have a day job on the technical
advisor and a number of bitcoin startups.
I am the chief security
officer for blockchain Info,
which is the largest bitcoin web wallet,
uh,
in the space.
Um,
and I work everyday as a media,
uh,
you know,
as a media pundits,
a commentator on bitcoin.
I write code and then I comment about
it and I do interviews all the time
because this is something
I believe in strongly.
I don't get paid for my interviews.
I have other jobs that allow me to pay
for international travel for a long time.
That was my savings account until,
uh,
until I was able to get other beans.
Buble you certainly hope to
eventually profit off of this.
Oh,
actually now I'm making income on Bitcoin,
so,
so let's,
so things are stabilized.
Uh,
you know,
I'm not a bitcoin millionaire.
I'm may never be a bitcoin millionaire,
but I know what career I want
to do for the next 15 years.
Wow.
So how did you know that bitcoin was
going to be worthwhile and that so many
people are going to jump on the board?
A jump of board two years ago,
it seems like two years ago it was like,
I didn't know.
I mean what I knew is this
is a very elegant technology.
The had some implications,
some geopolitical implications,
some cultural implications,
some technology implications.
And I liked all of those and I was
very interested in pursuing it.
And at the time I hoped it was
going to get baked and I figured,
you know,
if it didn't and uh,
and I didn't get anywhere with it,
I could do something else
in a couple of years.
You've got to come on again in a year.
I'd love to,
yeah,
let's,
let's let this thing cook out there.
In the crazy world,
I mean what we say a year,
but the way things are moving,
three months you might be right.
It was getting crazy in terms of
what happened in the last year alone.
It's been unbelievable.
I mean,
we had our first major bitcoin
conference in April in San Jose,
and now there's like a hundred
conferences going on this year.
Wow.
And there's $150 million transaction.
Right?
Exactly.
And the price was that,
you know what,
I was working on this,
the price was $15 I,
I,
if you asked me last year,
it did.
I think bitcoin would be at a thousand.
I said,
no,
y'all may be in a couple of years.
I was surprised too.
But you know,
it has a way of growing on you.
And when it does,
it grows as a network and people
find it useful and they try it.
They understand how it works,
it's practical.
They grasped the usefulness of it,
and they start using it.
I wish I had you in here when
Peter Schiff was in here.
I'd be like sick Andreas.
Tell him what's up.
Maybe he's right.
I don't know who's right or wrong.
No,
I don't generally debates on this because
the simple truth is that none of us
know.
Right.
And the reason we don't know is because
the tools we have to analyze currencies
don't apply because this is a
completely different type of currency.
It's not a stock,
it's not a currency.
It's not an asset.
It's not a commodity.
It's a bit of everything.
Um,
so can I tell you what
it's gonna do in two years?
Of course not.
I don't know.
Nobody knows.
What I do know is I understand the
technology and what I see as something
elegant and practical.
So I'm interested in seeing
where this experiment will go.
Because here's the thing,
if it doesn't work,
some people lose money.
If it does work.
We changed the world of money forever.
And that's a pretty big thing to say.
But cryptocurrencies I
think are here to stay.
They offer an elegant solution
to decentralized money.
And with a bit coin survives or not.
I want to see where this is going to
go because it has the possibility of
changing a lot of people's lives.
Well,
it certainly does.
And I want to see them
find that Nakamoto thing.
I want to see who it is.
Oh,
I hope they never find him.
Yeah,
cause you're,
you're,
it's like big foot for you
searching for a searching for sugar,
man.
For me,
I want to find them.
It's probably gonna be something you
already know to like the dude you got a
Dell guy or somebody.
It's unbelievably fascinating.
It's just unbelievably fascinating.
Especially listening to you describe it.
Um,
your,
your
passion for it makes it
even more fascinating.
It's a,
it's really something that I'm going
to keep my eyes on and try to follow.
So,
uh,
I appreciate you coming over
here and I appreciate you,
uh,
giving us your knowledge
and spending your time and,
and uh,
I guess I'll,
I'll set up,
I'll watch it on my phone now,
so,
yeah,
sure,
sure.
Absolutely.
And if we set up an android phone,
yes.
Right.
Okay.
So you can,
you can download the blockchain.
And I said before I,
I work for blockchain as
the chief security officer.
I was a customer long before that,
but I think it's one of the better ones.
Okay.
So you download blockchain
from your app store and a,
then you'll get an address.
And I can then send you some bitcoin
and you'll have it in a few seconds
to put up a computer here.
A dedicated computer that
runs can help you do that.
Coin computations wouldn't
fuck with us in any way,
right?
With,
no,
not at all.
Mess with our band.
Dan,
what's your electricity?
Electricity.
I mean you can get a little
one that's even a USB sticks.
They call it like a Klondike
insulate a little as stick USB stick.
You plug it in and he just swapped some
electricity and it generates a bitcoin.
You're not going to generate monster.
I'm not trying to get rich off.
Come off.
Maybe it's going to be
printed to play with.
That's cool.
Bit Coin Street credit.
That's what I'm looking for.
Yeah,
exactly.
All right.
Listen man,
this was very enlightening.
Um,
uh,
I'm obviously going to have to
read a lot of shit after this.
There's so much involved in this
subject and so much involved in crypto
currencies.
It's a,
it's really,
really interesting stuff,
but I think it's bad ass man.
And I really respect a guy like you
who takes a giant leap like that and,
and dives into something and something
that you believe in and you get really
passionate about it.
It's what life is about to me.
It's about pursuing passions and I love
the fact that you're really into it and
I really,
really appreciate you coming
on here and enlightening us.
Thank you so much for having me.
And you know,
sometimes you,
you choose the things
you want to do in life,
but some of the most
interesting things in life,
once you find them,
you have no choice.
I had no choice.
I couldn't sleep at night
if I wasn't doing this.
It's still a choice.
It was just such a,
it's such a big drop.
But yeah,
I mean I hope you see,
you know,
I'm not trying to sell anything.
I am genuinely passionate about this
because I see an elegant solution.
Yes.
Well that is where,
you know,
the choices,
the choices and being that person
who follows their passions,
that's inspirational to me.
It's one of the most inspirational
things I encounter both online and in the
real world is watching people who
are passionate about what they do
do.
Right.
You can recognize it in others.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's the only way to live your life
contagious for me.
Like it could be a guy
who makes handmade knives,
you know,
and grinds the blades and
sharpens the handles and,
you know,
puts everything together.
I have fascinating,
but I'm fascinated by anything that
someone's incredibly passionate about.
And,
uh,
so this,
this bit coin thing now
it's just now it's in there.
Now it's in my list of
things I'm fascinated about.
Right.
Well,
thank you very much.
So people want to get in touch with you.
Uh,
they can,
uh,
contact you on Twitter.
Probably the easiest thing is Twitter.
Yeah,
that's the one I can handle the most.
But listen,
you're going to get swarmed.
Try not to pay attention to
all those fucking psychos.
Okay.
It's a n t o n o p.
That's a n t o n o.
P on Twitter.
Um,
and,
uh,
entrance.
Is there anything else
that you have a website,
a antonopoulos.com.
Um,
yeah,
sure.
That's why media sites and people
can book me for engagements there,
but a really on Twitter
is where I'm most active.
My name is pretty easy to Google and
to thank you so much for having me.
I really,
yeah,
please is.
It was an honor.
Um,
I really think we had like a
crazy internet pioneer in here.
This is good.
Some day we're going to
look back on this and say,
man,
we have Andrea from,
I know we should a bought
that coin and apple stock.
Let us know what the fuck is.
He told us not to.
We could have had a whole
room full of computers.
Man,
we shouldn't listen to him.
Back then.
He didn't have enough faith.
Uh,
thanks a lot man.
Awesome.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Uh,
to everyone else.
Next big date I got coming up folks,
uh,
is um,
I am in Dallas,
Texas with Ari Shaffir
and Duncan Trussell.
That's March 14th at the
Verizon theater this weekend,
this Friday.
Um,
uh,
um,
it's sold out.
I mean New York,
but don't try to get tickets because if
you do get tickets and just support and
scalpers,
so unless you find somebody online that's,
that can't go cause they're posts,
it got wet,
but whatever.
Do what you gotta do folks.
Um,
so that's the next big one.
Uh,
is uh,
Dallas,
Verizon theater.
March 14th.
Can't fucking wait.
That's the day before the huge
UFC event at Dallas stadium,
which is apparently like
50,000 seats or something.
Bananas.
So that should be a lot of fun.
Um,
that's it.
All right,
you freaks.
We'll be back this week with uh,
many more podcasts to be scheduled
and many more conversations to be had.
A much more fun and uh,
and much love.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thank you to squarespace.com the greatest
resource online for creating websites.
Go to squarespace.com and use the
offer code Joe and the number one.
That's one word,
Joe and the number one and save
10% off your first purchase.
Squarespace is the first place you
should stop if you're even thinking about
making a website.
Thank you.
Also to legal zoom.com go and do your
legal stuff online at legal zoom without
going to a goddamn lawyers office.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you with a third
party attorney if shit goes off the rails
and they can also provide
you with self help services.
When you check out,
use the code word Rogan in the referral
box and thank you also to onnit.com
that's o.
N,
n.
I.
T.
Use the Codeword Rogan and save
10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
you fox.
We love the shit out ya
and we'll see you soon.
Big Kiss.